NOW WILL COME TO ORDER. THANK
YOU ALL, FOR JOINING US AT THIS
MEETING. THE SENATE WELCOMES THE
PUBLIC IN PERSON, AND WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE MEETINGS
HERE IN THE STATE CAPITOL. I ASK
ALL MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO
PLEASE BE PRESENT IN ROOM 113 SO
WE CAN ESTABLISH OUR QUORUM AND
BEGIN OUR HEARING, WE HAD SEVEN
TÍNH BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA,
THREE OF WHICH ARE ON CONSENT.
ITEM 6AB 2117 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PATTERSON. ITEM 13 A B 2939 BY
SPEAKER EMERITUS RENDON AND ITEM
17 A, B 3276 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAMOS. IN ADDITION, WE HAVE A
FEW HOUSEKEEPING NOTES FILE
SEVEN AB 2729 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JOE PATTERSON HAS BEEN PULLED.
FILE 11 AB 2791 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WILSON HAS BEEN PULLED,
WE ALSO HAVE A HARD OUT AT NOON.
SO I ENCOURAGE ALL AUTHORS AND
WITNESSES TO PLEASE BE BRIEF IN
YOUR COMMENTS. TO THE EXTENT
POSSIBLE, WE DO NOT CURRENTLY
HAVE A QUORUM, SO WE WILL START
BY OPERATING AS A SUBCOMMITTEE,
NOW LET'S HEAR FROM OUR FIRST
AUTHOR. AUTHOR FOR SEVERAL
BILLS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN.
GOOD MORNING. WELCOME. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR, MY FIRST
BILL IS AB 930, FIRST, I'M GOING
TO BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS STARTING ON PAGE TEN.
COMMENT FIVE OF THE ANALYSIS. I
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE AND
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
WORK ON THE BILL. MANY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WOULD LIKE TO BOOST
INVESTMENT IN INFRASTRUCTURE AND
TRANSIT ORIENTED INFILL
DEVELOPMENT. HOWEVER, LACK OF
ACCESS TO FUNDING AND PROJECTS
ARE NOT ECONOMICALLY FEASIBLE.
SORRY ACCESSING FUNDING AND
PROJECTS ARE NOT ECONOMICALLY
FEASIBLE DUE TO A LACK OF
AVAILABLE LAND, HIGH
INFRASTRUCTURE COSTS, WEAK
MARKET COMPS, AND EXPENSIVE AND
RISKY ENTITLEMENT PROCESSES. IN
1945, CALIFORNIA ENACTED THE
CALIFORNIA REDEVELOPMENT ACT TO
ASSIST LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN
ELIMINATING BLIGHT THROUGH
DEVELOPMENT. THIS PROGRAM
ALLOWED REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES
TO USE STATE AND LOCAL
INCREMENTAL TAX, PROPERTY TAX TO
SUPPORT REDEVELOPMENT. THIS
PROGRAM WAS SUCCESSFUL IN
ELIMINATING BLIGHT AND RESULTED
IN THOUSANDS OF NEW HOUSING
UNITS OVER THE COURSE OF ITS 67
YEAR HISTORY, INCLUDING A LOT IN
MY DISTRICT. THESE THAT. THIS
PROGRAM WAS DISSOLVED, HOWEVER,
IN 2012, AB 930 WILL PERMIT TWO
OR MORE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
JOINTLY FORM A REINVESTMENT IN
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR A SUSTAINABLE
AND EQUITABLE CALIFORNIA KNOWN
AS ARISE DISTRICT, TO UNLOCK TAX
INCREMENT FINANCING FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE, AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND EQUITABLE
DEVELOPMENT AND LOCATION
EFFICIENT AREAS. THIS IS
COMPLETELY AN OPT IN FOR
MUNICIPAL CITIES AND LOCALITIES.
NO ONE'S FORCING THEM TO DO
THIS. REYES DISTRICT PLANS WILL
ALIGN WITH METROPOLITAN PLANNING
ORGANIZATIONS, SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITY STRATEGIES, WHILE
TARGETING INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS THAT SUPPORT
EQUITABLE DEVELOPMENT AND
EXISTING COMMUNITY CENTERS,
WHILE REDUCING CAR DEPENDANCE,
LOWERING CARBON EMISSIONS, AND
ENCOURAGING ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
AND CLIMATE RESILIENT HOUSING
PRODUCTION. NEAR TRANSIT AND
WALKABLE COMMUNITIES. THE RISE
ACT WILL ALIGN PLANNING AND
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS TO
REFOCUS GROWTH TOWARDS COMMUNITY
CENTERS WHILE REDUCING. THE BILL
IS SPONSORED BY THE COUNCIL OF
INFILL BUILDERS, SPUR AND CIVIC
WELL AND IS SUPPORTED BY
CALIFORNIA HOME BUILDING
ALLIANCE, THE CITY OF OAKLAND,
MONTEREY COUNTY AND SCAG.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT TODAY ARE
MIA KANG, SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT
WITH RELATED CALIFORNIA AND
DIRECTOR OF THE COUNCIL OF
INFILL BUILDINGS. AND ROGER
DICKINSON, POLICY DIRECTOR WITH
CIVIC WEALTH. ROGER HI, ROGER,
WITH THAT, I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE WHEN YOU
HAVE A QUORUM, I. GOOD MORNING,
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS, MY NAME
IS MIA CØNG, AND I AM THE. I'M A
SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT WITH
RELATED CALIFORNIA AND ONE OF
THE FOUNDING BOARD MEMBERS OF
THE COUNCIL OF INFILL BUILDERS,
AND WE'RE ONE OF THE BILLS,
PROUD CO-SPONSORS. I'VE BEEN
DEVELOPING AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
CALIFORNIA FOR THE LAST 2500.
I'M SORRY. FOR THE LAST 25
YEARS, I'VE BUILT ALMOST I'VE
BUILT ALMOST 2000 UNITS OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE STATE.
SO I STARTED MY CAREER WORKING
WITH REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES WHO
ONCE PLAYED AN ENORMOUS ROLE IN
CREATING AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
THE STATE. REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCIES WERE REQUIRED TO SET
ASIDE 20% OF THEIR REVENUES TO
CREATE AND REHABILITATE AND
PRESERVE AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
PRIOR TO THE ELIMINATION OF RDAS
IN 2012, IT WAS ESTIMATED THAT
RDAS CONTRIBUTED ABOUT $1
BILLION A YEAR TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING, AND THIS WAS THE
LARGEST POOL OF NONFEDERAL MONEY
THAT WAS AVAILABLE FOR
AFFORDABLE HOMES IN THE STATE.
TODAY, THE MAJORITY OF THE
FUNDING FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IS AWARDED THROUGH COMPETITIVE
STATE PROGRAMS. LAST YEAR, HCD
SUPERNOVA, AS IT'S KNOWN, WAS
AWARDED $576 MILLION TO FUND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. HOWEVER, THE
TOTAL AMOUNT REQUESTED BY
QUALIFIED DEVELOPERS AND
PROJECTS AROUND THE STATE WAS
MORE THAN $3.5 BILLION,
REPRESENTING OVER 20,000 UNITS
FOR THE MAJORITY OF PROJECTS
THAT WERE NOT FUNDED, THEY WERE
MOTHBALLED AND WERE, YOU KNOW,
WAITING FOR, YOU KNOW, THE
FOLLOWING YEAR TO REQUEST
FUNDING, IT IS COMMON RIGHT NOW
FOR DEVELOPMENTS TO INCUR ABOUT
TEN DIFFERENT LAYERS OF FUNDING
TO MAKE AFFORDABLE HOUSING WORK.
AND SOMETIMES IT CAN TAKE A
DECADE TO BRING ALL THE FUNDING
TOGETHER. AB 930 WILL PERMIT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO FORM RISE
DISTRICTS TO LEVERAGE TAX
INCREMENT FINANCING FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. 50% OF THE FUNDING WILL
BE REQUIRED TO BE SPENT ON
SUPPORTIVE INFRASTRUCTURE TO
HELP THOSE COMMUNITIES WITH
TRANSIT AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
INFRASTRUCTURE, 30% OF THE MONEY
WILL BE IN NEW DEDICATED SOURCE
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING, AND ALL
THE UNITS ARE REQUIRED TO BE
DEED RESTRICTED. AB 930 ALSO
ESTABLISHES A NEW REVOLVING LOAN
FUND AT I BANK THAT WILL HELP TO
JUMPSTART GROWTH IN NEW RISE
DISTRICTS THAT WILL HELP TO FUND
INFRASTRUCTURE TO HELP JUMP
START THE RISE PLANS IN SUBURBAN
, RURAL AND URBAN COMMUNITIES.
REDUCING CAR DEPENDANCE AND
LOWERING CARBON EMISSIONS. AB
930 WILL INCENTIVIZE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO WORK TO WORK
COLLABORATIVELY TOGETHER TO
LEVERAGE RESOURCES AND ALIGN
CLIMATE PLANNING AND STRATEGIC
INVESTMENTS IN INFRASTRUCTURE
AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AB 930
WILL PROVIDE SUSTAINABLE, LONG
TERM FINANCING THAT WILL EMPOWER
LOCAL COMMUNITIES TO BUILD MORE
EQUITABLE HOUSING AND CREATE
MORE RESILIENT COMMUNITIES. WE
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR HER
VISIONARY LEADERSHIP, AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR THE
COMMITTEE'S AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANKS, MAYOR. SORRY, I DID
ANNOUNCE EARLIER THAT WE HAVE
TWO MINUTES FOR EACH AND IF YOU
DID IT IN LESS TIME, IT WOULD BE
EVEN GREATER. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. GOOD MORNING.
I'M ROGER DICKINSON, THE POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR CIVIC. WELL
PREVIOUSLY THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMISSION. AND I WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN FOR HER
LEADERSHIP AND GREAT DESCRIPTION
OF THE BILL. I'VE BEEN DEEPLY
INVOLVED IN EFFORTS TO INTEGRATE
LAND USE AND TRANSPORTATION FOR
MULTIPLE DECADES AS A COUNTY
SUPERVISOR, AS A MEMBER OF THE
ASSEMBLY, AND AS A CITIZEN TO
PROMOTE A STRONGER ECONOMY, A
HEALTHIER ENVIRONMENT AND
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES,
INCLUDING AS A PRINCIPAL
COAUTHOR OF SB 628 BY SENATOR
BELL. IN 2014, WHICH AUTHORIZED
THE CREATION OF APHIDS. PARDON
ME AB 930, BUILT ON THE CONCEPT
OF APHIDS BY ALLOWING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO DEDICATE GROWTH
AND LOCAL PROPERTY TAX REVENUE
TO FINANCE INVESTMENTS IN
INFRASTRUCTURE AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND GEOGRAPHIC AREAS
NEAR TRANSIT AND IN LOCATION
EFFICIENT SITES. AND SO DOING.
AB 930 PROVIDES A FORM OF VALUE
CAPTURE PROPERTIES THAT ENJOY
ENHANCED VALUE DUE TO THEIR
PROXIMITY TO TRANSIT OR OTHER
DESIRABLE LOCATION WILL HELP
UNDERWRITE THE COST OF PUBLIC
INVESTMENT. LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WILL BE ABLE TO FOCUS THAT
INVESTMENT WHERE IT WILL YIELD
THE GREATEST RETURN IN FOSTERING
THE ELEMENTS IN WHICH
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES DEPEND.
A GREATER SUPPLY OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN A DEVELOPMENT PATTERN
THAT REDUCES TRIPS AND
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS, AND A
SETTING THAT PROVIDES
WALKABILITY AND SOCIAL COHESION,
AB 930 CAN JUMP START PROJECTS
THAT WILL BRING RESULTS THROUGH
THE CONCEPT OF A STATE REVOLVING
LOAN FUND, AS MISS KHÔNG
DESCRIBED. AND IT DOVETAILS
NICELY WITH AB 2011. SB SIX AB
930 PROVIDES A SIGNIFICANT NEW
TOOL FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
USE AS THEY ENDEAVOR TO GROW
SMARTER, AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE FOR AB
930. THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
APPRECIATE IT, AND NOW SO DO WE
HAVE ANY MORE, IN SUPPORT OF AB
930 MICHAEL AND WHISPER
CO-SPONSOR AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. RAFA
SONNENFELD WITH THE MBA ACTION
IN SUPPORT. AND ON BEHALF OF OUR
CHAPTERS AND MEMBERS, INCLUDING
EAST BAY FOR EAST BAY, YIMBY,
MOUNTAIN VIEW, YIMBY, NORTHERN
NEIGHBORS PENINSULA FOR EVERYONE
, SAN FRANCISCO, YIMBY, SANTA
CRUZ, EMB SANTA SANTA ROSA,
YIMBY, SLOW C¢M URBAN
ENVIRONMENTALIST, GROW, THE
RICHMOND, VENTURA COUNTY YIMBY
STREETS FOR PEOPLE, SOUTH SIDE
FORWARD. HOW TO ADU PEOPLE FOR
HOUSING. ORANGE COUNTY PROGRESS
NÓ VALLEY, SOUTH BAY, YIMBY AND
NAPA SOLANO FOR EVERYONE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, CHARLES WATSON. ON
BEHALF OF BART, WE HAD A SUPPORT
OF AMENDED POSITION, BUT WITH
THE RECENT AMENDMENTS ARE
SUPPORTIVE. NOW. THANK YOU TO
THE AUTHOR. APPRECIATE IT. THANK
YOU. KASHA HUNT WITH NORSEMAN ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF MONTEREY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. BOB NAYLOR
FOR FIELDSTEAD AND COMPANY.
THAT'S HOWARD AHMANSON JR, AN
ORANGE COUNTY PHILANTHROPIST
MOVING FROM OPPOSE TO SUPPORT
BASED ON THE AMENDMENT FOR WHICH
WE THANK THE AUTHOR BANNING
EMINENT DOMAIN. THANK YOU, MARK
VUKOVICH ON BEHALF OF STREETS
FOR ALL IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ANY MORE IN SUPPORT? SEEING NONE
, ANYONE IN OPPOSITION, PLEASE
COME FORWARD. GOOD MORNING,
KATIE HARDIMAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION.
UNFORTUNATELY, IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY. ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION?
SEEING NONE COME TO THE DAIS,
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS?
COLLEAGUES OKAY. THE MOVE. WE
DON'T HAVE THE FORM. OKAY SO
WHEN WE DO HAVE A QUORUM, THEN
WE WILL TAKE UP THE MOTION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THIS
PRESENTATION, ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
MOVE ON TO AB 1889. VERY MUCH.
FIRST I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
SUGGESTED COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
MENTIONED ON PAGE FIVE. COMMENT
FOUR OF THE ANALYSIS, AB 1889
REQUIRES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
CONSIDER AND MINIMIZE IMPACTS TO
WILDLIFE MOVEMENT AND HABITAT
CONNECTIVITY AS PART OF THE
CONSERVATION ELEMENT OF THEIR
GENERAL PLAN. IN CONSULTATION
WITH STATE AND LOCAL AGENCIES.
STARTING WITH THE NEXT GENERAL
PLAN UPDATE AFTER JANUARY 1ST,
2028, THE CALIFORNIA, AS YOU
KNOW, HAS A VERY RICH RESOURCES
IN TERMS OF ITS BIODIVERSITY.
BUT WHEN WE BUILD WITHOUT
THINKING OF THE MIGRATORY PATHS
OF THESE ANIMALS, A LOT OF TIMES
WE END UP WITH UNNECESSARY AND
OFTEN DANGEROUS INTERACTIONS
BETWEEN HUMANS AND WILDLIFE,
PARTICULARLY LARGE WILDLIFE.
THIS CAN BE AVOIDED IF WE JUST
DID A LITTLE BETTER PLANNING UP
FRONT. FIGURE OUT WHERE ANIMALS
ARE MIGRATING. THE BEST PATH TO
GET THEM TO MIGRATE THROUGH
AREAS, AND THEN BUILD AROUND
THAT AND PROTECT THOSE
CORRIDORS. RIGHT NOW IN LOS
ANGELES, WE'RE HAVING TO GO BACK
AND ADD WILDLIFE CORRIDORS,
WHICH IS EXPENSIVE. WE HAVE WE
SEE LARGE MIGRATORY ANIMALS,
PARTICULARLY DEER, CAUSING HUMAN
DEATHS EVERY YEAR ON OUR
ROADWAYS. THAT DOESN'T HAVE TO
HAPPEN IF WE JUST DO THE
PLANNING THAT WE NEED UP FRONT,
I, SOME JURISDICTIONS LIKE
VENTURA COUNTY, HAVE VOLUNTARILY
ADOPTED WILDLIFE CONNECTIVITY
POLICIES, BUT IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE HAVE STATEWIDE
IMPLEMENTATION. THESE ANIMALS
DON'T RECOGNIZE THOSE
BOUNDARIES. AND I WANT TO STRESS
THAT AB 1889 IS NOT CREATING ANY
NEW PROTECTIONS OR PROGRAMS OR
PROVIDING FOR MORE ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITY. AND IF YOU'RE WORRIED
ABOUT THIS PROGRAM STOPPING NEW
HOUSING, RECOGNIZE THAT HOUSING
IS STOPPED WHEN SOMEONE BUYS A
PIECE OF LAND, COMES UP WITH A
PLAN BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT WAS IN
THE GENERAL PLAN AND GOES TO
BUILD ON IT, DOES AN EIR, AND
THEN GETS HIT WITH SOMEONE
SAYING, HEY, YOU'VE GOT
MIGRATORY ANIMALS. IT'S MUCH
BETTER FOR DEVELOPERS TO KNOW UP
FRONT AND TO COME RIGHT IN WITH
THEIR PLAN, WITH A MITIGATION
PLAN LIKE FENCING OR A LITTLE
PATH OR A DITCH OR WHATEVER IT
IS UP FRONT. SO THIS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT CONNECTIVITY.
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
WHOLESALE PUTTING LARGE PIECES
OF LAND ASIDE FOR THESE ANIMALS.
THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS BILL IS
ABOUT. IT'S SIMPLY ABOUT
MIGRATING ANIMALS, NOTHING IN AB
1889 REQUIRES LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO CONSTRUCT NEW
WILDLIFE CROSSINGS OVER EXISTING
ROADS OR HIGHWAYS. THIS IS
REALLY ENCOURAGING LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO TAKE A HOLISTIC
APPROACH AS THEY PLAN IN THE
FUTURE. IT ALSO GIVES LOCAL
JURISDICTION ACCESS TO TOOLS BY
HAVING STATE AGENCIES BE
AVAILABLE TO THEM. SO REALLY,
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BE
A NO BRAINER. EASY. I TODAY
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT IS FORMER
VENTURA COUNTY SUPERVISOR LINDA
PARKS AND JOSHUA HUG WITH
MIDPENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT. THIS BILL, BY THE WAY,
HAS HAD BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
WOULD REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. HI. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR DURAZO AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I'M LINDA
PARKS. I'M A FORMER PLANNING
COMMISSIONER, COUNCIL MEMBER,
MAYOR AND RECENTLY RETIRED FROM
THE VENTURA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. DURING MY TIME ON
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS, WE
ADOPTED AND IMPLEMENTED VENTURA
COUNTY'S WILDLIFE CORRIDOR
ORDINANCE. AND I'M HERE TO TELL
YOU TODAY THAT AB 1889 IS NEEDED
AND VERY FEASIBLE. LIKE VENTURA
COUNTY'S ORDINANCE, AB 1889
PROVIDES CLEAR DIRECTIVE TO
PLANNERS AND DEVELOPERS TO
CONSIDER WILDLIFE CROSSINGS AND
WILDLIFE CORRIDORS IN THE
PLANNING PROCESS, PLANNERS CAN
USE EXISTING RESOURCES SUCH AS
CALIFORNIA FISH AND WILDLIFE
ESSENTIAL HABITAT CONNECTIVITY
DATA, AND DEVELOPERS WILL KNOW
EARLY IN THE DEVELOPMENT PROCESS
WHAT IS EXPECTED OF THEM. THIS
WILL MINIMIZE THE NEED FOR
PROJECT CHANGES LATER ON, AND IT
SAVES MONEY AND TIME AND IT WILL
ALSO MINIMIZE THE NEED FOR
PROJECT CHANGES. AB 1889 WON'T
PREVENT DEVELOPMENT, RATHER, IT
CALLS FOR THINGS LIKE WILDLIFE
FRIENDLY LIGHTING AND FENCING,
AND LANDSCAPING DON'T PLANT
INVASIVE PLANTS, FOR EXAMPLE,
AND WHERE POSSIBLE, DO CLUSTER
DEVELOPMENT INSTEAD OF HARMFUL
URBAN SPRAWL. WE KNOW THAT SEQUA
ALREADY REQUIRES THAT THE
PROJECT LEVEL LOOKING AT
WILDLIFE CORRIDOR IMPACTS, BUT
THIS ALLOWS FOR ALL FOUNDATIONAL
SCIENTIFIC INFORMATION TO BE ALL
IN ONE PLACE. THE CONSERVATION
ELEMENT OF GENERAL PLANS, WE
WOULD LIKE TO ASK THAT YOU
FACILITATE, HELP, FACILITATE
BETTER REGIONAL PLANNING BY
ADOPTING AB 1889. IT WILL ALSO
HELP AVOID THE UNNECESSARY
EXTINCTION OF ICONIC WILDLIFE
LIKE MOUNTAIN LIONS. AND WHILE
I'M HERE, I JUST WANT TO THANK
YOU AND ALSO THE GOVERNOR FOR
YOUR INVESTMENT IN WILDLIFE
INFRASTRUCTURE, LIKE CROSSINGS,
LIKE THE WALLIS ANNENBERG
BRIDGE, WHICH IS CURRENTLY BEING
BUILT IN AGOURA, OVER THE 101
FREEWAY, THE LARGEST WILDLIFE
BRIDGE IN THE WORLD, AND BECAUSE
OF VENTURA COUNTY'S WILDLIFE
CORRIDOR AND WILDLIFE CORRIDOR
ORDINANCE, WILDLIFE CROSSING
THAT BRIDGE WILL HAVE CONNECTED
OPEN SPACE ON EITHER SIDE. SO
JUST URGING YOUR SUPPORT TO
ALLOW A ROOM TO ROAM. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT WITNESS. OOPS MORNING,
CHAIR. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR HUESO
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS JOSH HUG. I'M THE
GOVERNMENTAL AFFAIRS PROGRAM
MANAGER FOR THE MIDPENINSULA
REGIONAL OPEN SPACE DISTRICT.
MID-PEN IS A SPECIAL DISTRICT
LOCATED ON THE SAN FRANCISCO
PENINSULA THAT HAS, FOR THE PAST
50 YEARS, HAD A THREE PART
MISSION ACQUIRE AND PRESERVE
OPEN SPACE, LAND, PROTECT AND
RESTORE THE NATURAL ENVIRONMENT,
AND PROVIDE ECOLOGICALLY
SENSITIVE PUBLIC ENJOYMENT AND
EDUCATION. TO DATE, WE HAVE
PROTECTED AND MANAGED OVER
72,000 ACRES OF OPEN SPACE. NEXT
TO SILICON VALLEY. AS AN AGENCY
THAT IS SHEPHERDING TWO LARGE
SCALE HABITAT CONNECTIVITY
PROJECTS SERVING WILDLIFE AS
LARGE AS MOUNTAIN LIONS AND AS
SMALL AS NEWTS. WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR AB 1889. THIS BILL
PROVIDES LOCAL JURISDICTIONS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO IDENTIFY,
ESTABLISH AND PROTECT HABITAT
CONNECTED K¾T WHILE ALLOWING
DEVELOPMENT AND LOCATIONS THAT
MAY BE LESS BENEFICIAL TO LOCAL
WILDLIFE, WILDLIFE ARE DOING
THEIR BEST TO SURVIVE DESPITE
INTENSE PRESSURE FROM HUMAN
DEVELOPMENT, INCLUDING ROADWAYS,
WATER AND POWER LINES, AND
INTENSIFIED RESIDENTIAL AND
RECREATIONAL USES FOR OUR TWO
PROJECTS, WILDLIFE ARE FACING
ALL OF THESE FACTORS, AND THEY
NEED THE ABILITY TO SAFELY MOVE
THROUGH AND ACROSS THE REMAINING
HABITAT. CONNECTIONS ARE VITALLY
IMPORTANT FOR BOTH PEOPLE AND
WILDLIFE. THEY ARE ABLE TO LIVE
LONGER AND THRIVE WHEN THEY ARE
CONNECTED AND CAN FREELY MOVE
BETWEEN PLACES THEY NEED TO
SURVIVE. PEOPLE BENEFIT FROM
THESE HEALTHY, CONNECTED
ECOSYSTEMS THROUGH CLEAN AIR,
FILTERED, WATER POLLINATED CROPS
AND HEALTHY SOILS. TODAY HABITAT
CONNECTIVITY REQUIRES LARGE
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS THAT CAN
COST TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
. THE. LET'S BUILD UPON THESE
VOTER SUPPORTED PROJECTS BY
ENSURING THAT OPEN SPACES ARE
RECONNECTED AND PROTECTED FROM
FUTURE DEVELOPMENT THAT WOULD
FURTHER FRAGMENT HABITAT.
THOUGHTFUL LAND USE PLANNING CAN
CONNECT OUR LANDSCAPE AND
PROVIDE ACCESS TO INTACT NATURAL
AREAS FOR FUTURE GENERATIONS,
WHILE BRINGING THE STATE CLOSER
TO ITS 30 BY 30 GOALS. IN
SUMMARY, 1889 IS CRUCIAL AS IT
ADDRESSES THE PRESSING NEED TO
IDENTIFY AND SAFEGUARD WILDLIFE
CORRIDORS IN CALIFORNIA TO
MITIGATE HABITAT FRAGMENTATION,
PRESERVE BIODIVERSITY AND ADAPT
TO THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE I'D LIKE TO
MEET TO IN SUPPORT OF AB 1889?
GOOD MORNING, ABIGAIL SCHMIDT,
ON BEHALF OF THE EAST BAY
REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT AND THE
LAND TRUST OF SANTA CRUZ COUNTY
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, AARON WOOLLEY WITH
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT, NATALIE
BROWN WITH THE PLANNING
CONSERVATION LEAGUE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. SEEING NO
ONE ELSE IN SUPPORT ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB 1889. GOOD
MORNING. GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR. MEMBERS, STEVE CRUZ, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION.
AND WE DO HAVE AN OPPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION ON AB 1889.
WE'VE BEEN CONCERNED THAT AB
1889 WOULD REQUIRE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO MODIFY THE
CONSERVATION ELEMENT WITHIN
THEIR GENERAL PLAN IN SUCH A WAY
THAT WOULD EXPAND THE SCOPE AND
SCALE OF THE ELEMENT BEYOND
PUBLIC LANDS, AND REQUIRE LEVELS
OF MITIGATION THAT SHOULD BE
DEALT WITH AT THE PROJECT LEVEL,
AND IN DOING SO, PUT RESTRICTION
ON ON HOUSING DEVELOPMENT.
HOWEVER, WE'VE HAD POSITIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE, CATCHING UP WITH THE
CONSULTANT BEHIND YOU HERE. SOME
OF THESE AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN
ACCEPTED, SO I WILL BE BRIEF,
THERE'S A FEW REMAINING ISSUES,
BUT JUST VERY QUICKLY TO TOUCH
ON THEM, WE WERE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE LACK OF INCLUSION OF THE
WORD FEASIBILITY IN SECTION
65302. SO THERE'S BEEN SOME
ACCEPTANCE OF THAT. AND I WOULD
LIKE TO CONTINUE TO WORK TO
ENSURE THAT IT'S, EQUAL TO OTHER
ELEMENTS IN THAT REGARD. AND
THEN TWO, THERE WAS A CHANGE
THAT I UNDERSTAND WAS NOW MADE,
FROM AND OR SO THAT WE DON'T
HAVE TO MITIGATE IF WE HAVE
AVOIDED IMPACT ON WILDLIFE. SO
THANK YOU FOR THAT. AND THEN
WE'D LIKE TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THE DEFINITION OF WILDLIFE. WE
HAD SOME CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE, BUT WE'D LIKE
TO AT LEAST KEEP THAT DOOR OPEN
TO HAVE CONTINUED CONVERSATIONS.
SO OKAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION TO AB
1889? GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. BRADY GERNAN ON BEHALF
OF THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES AND A RESPECTFUL OPPOSING
LÀ SUBMITTED. WANTED TO THANK
THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE. THE
AMENDMENTS ARE MOVING THE BILL
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION. WE DO
BELIEVE THAT IT WOULD BE MORE
EFFICIENT TO HAVE IT CONTINGENT
UPON AB 2320, WHICH IS MOVING
THROUGH THAT WOULD MAP OUT THESE
WILDLIFE CORRIDORS FOR EASIER,
MAKE IT EASIER FOR OUR CITIES
AND OUR STAFF TO DO THAT, CAL
CITIES HAS SUPPORTED THAT BILL,
SO WE WANT TO SEE THAT UPON
THAT. BUT WE THINK THE BILL IS
MOVING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
LOOK FORWARD TO THOSE CONTINUED
CONVERSATIONS. THANK YOU. GREAT
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION? OKAY. SEEING NONE,
WE COME TO THE DÍAS. YES SENATOR
WIENER. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR,
AND THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR. WE
HAD A TEXT EXCHANGE YESTERDAY
ABOUT THIS, AND, AND I
APPRECIATE YOU WORKING WITH,
WITH THE HOUSING FOLKS ON THIS.
I'LL BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL,
AND IT'S AN IMPORTANT ISSUE. BUT
WHEN I SAW IT, IT DID SET OFF
SOME ALARM BELLS TO ME, BECAUSE
I ALSO KNOW, THAT SOMETIMES THE
BEST, CRAFT NOTED. ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTIONS CAN BE ABUSED BY BAD
FAITH ACTORS WHO ARE REALLY NOT
CONCERNED ABOUT WILDLIFE, BUT
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT STOPPING NEW
HOUSING IN THEIR COMMUNITY. WE
SAW THIS IN THE MOST, DRAMATIC
WAY. AND YOU'LL REMEMBER THIS
WHEN THE CITY OF WOODSIDE, IN
BAD FAITH, PRONOUNCED ITSELF THE
ENTIRE CITY WAS A MOUNTAIN LION,
REFUGE OR WHATEVER WORDING THEY
USE. AND THEIR GOAL WAS TO
EXEMPT THEMSELVES FROM STATE
HOUSING LAW BECAUSE HONESTLY,
BECAUSE OF THIS, LEGISLATURE HAS
A HABIT OF PUTTING IN VERY VAGUE
, EXEMPTIONS IN THE STATE
HOUSING LAWS, AND THEY AND
WOODSIDE TRIED TO ABUSE THAT.
FORTUNATELY, THE MOUNTAIN LION
ADVOCATES CAME FORWARD AND SAID
NO, DUPLEXES ARE NOT HARMFUL TO
MOUNTAIN LIONS. AND IT WAS JUST
AN ABSURD, FRIVOLOUS ARGUMENT BY
WOODSIDE. BUT HONESTLY, IT GAVE
A BLACK EYE TO A LOT OF
DIFFERENT EFFORTS, LIKE
LEGITIMATE EFFORTS LIKE THIS TO
PROTECT WILDLIFE. SO I, I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS IS
NOT GOING TO CREATE YET ANOTHER
TOOL FOR BAD FAITH ACTORS WHO
WANT TO OPPOSE HOUSING TO DO SO,
PURPORTEDLY IN THE NAME OF
WILDLIFE, SO CAN YOU JUST MAYBE
JUST COMMENT ON THAT GENERAL
ISSUE? AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH, WITH
THE OPPOSITION. TOTALLY
APPRECIATE THE CONCERN. AND IT'S
A VERY REASONABLE ONE, AND WHICH
IS WHY WE WORKED TO STRIKE THIS
BALANCE. I WOULD SAY THAT IN MY
EXPERIENCE, AND I LIKE YOU, I
COME FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT WHEN
FOLKS COME UP TO BRING UP THINGS
LIKE WILDLIFE TO BLOCK PROJECTS,
IT'S USUALLY AT THE PROJECT
LEVEL. SOMEONE'S PROPOSED A
SPECIFIC PROJECT, THEY'RE
LOOKING FOR A WAY TO STOP IT,
AND THEY'LL COME UP WITH AN
EXCUSE. I ACTUALLY THINK THAT
MOVING SOME OF THIS, MOVING THIS
PLANNING TO THE GENERAL PLAN
STAGE TAKE PEOPLE AREN'T AS
LIKELY, I BELIEVE, TO START TO,
TO LOOK AT SPECIFIC AREAS AND
SAY, WELL, YOU CAN'T HAVE
DEVELOPMENT THERE. YOU CAN HAVE
DEVELOPMENT THERE. BECAUSE WHAT
YOU'D BE LOOKING AT AT, AT, AT
THE AT WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT
THE, AT THAT EARLY STAGES, DO WE
HAVE MIGRATORY ANIMALS FIRST OF
ALL. AND IF SO WHERE ARE THEY
GOING. AND HOW DO WE JUST MAKE
SURE THAT THEY CAN MOVE THROUGH
WITHOUT HAVING CONFLICTS BETWEEN
PEOPLE AND BY BY DOING THAT WORK
UP FRONT WHEN PROJECTS DO COME
IN AT THE LATER STAGE, THAT WORK
HAS ALREADY BEEN DONE. AND IF
SOMEONE COMES IN AND SAYS, WHAT
ABOUT THE DEER? THEY CAN SAY,
HEY, THE CITY ALREADY HAS THIS
MITIGATION PLAN. WE'VE ADOPTED
THE MITIGATION PLAN. IT'S BEEN
INCORPORATED INTO OUR
DEVELOPMENT, AND IT TAKES THE
WIND OUT OF THE SAILS OF
SOMEBODY WHO'S GOING TO OPPOSE A
PROJECT AT THE PROJECT LEVEL. SO
I ACTUALLY, FROM MY EXPERIENCE,
BELIEVE LIKE FOR INSTANCE, WHEN
I WAS DOING HISTORIC
PRESERVATION IN GLENDALE BY
DOING A WINDSHIELD SURVEY UP
FRONT AND IDENTIFYING THOSE
PROPERTIES, IT LET THE
DEVELOPERS KNOW WHAT THEY WERE
GETTING INTO RIGHT AWAY FROM THE
GET GO. THAT PROJECT'S BEEN
IDENTIFIED AS POTENTIALLY A
HISTORIC STRUCTURE. MAYBE I
BETTER THINK TWICE BEFORE I
PURCHASE IT, PUT ALL THE MONEY
INTO IT. INSTEAD, THEY SAID THIS
PROJECT WAS SURVEYED, NOT
HISTORIC. I KNOW GOING IN, I'M
NOT GOING TO HAVE THAT FIGHT.
AND SO IT MADE THAT PROCESS AT
THE PROJECT LEVEL A LOT
SMOOTHER. AND SO THAT'S HOW I
ENVISION THIS WORKING. YEAH. AND
I THINK WITH WITH CITIES ACTING
IN GOOD FAITH, THAT WILL 100% BE
THE CASE, WE KNOW THAT OF THE
500 CITIES, THERE ARE SOME BAD
FAITH ACTORS WHO WILL SOME
CITIES THAT COULD USE THIS TO
TRY TO PUT STUFF IN THERE, TO
TRY TO POISON THE WELL AT THE
PROJECT LEVEL. SO WE HAVE TO BE
MINDFUL OF THAT. BUT I AM
SUPPORTING THE BILL AND I
APPRECIATE YOU WORKING WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS ON IT. THANK YOU.
YES, SENATOR DARLING, SAID A
COUPLE COMMENTS AND THEN A
QUESTION AS WELL, I CAME OUT OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENT, DID GENERAL
PLANS FOR COUNTIES, THOSE
PROCESSES SOMETIMES TAKE TEN
YEARS AND YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO DO
THEM EVERY TEN YEARS. BUT WE
HAD, AT LEAST IN THE RURAL PARTS
OF THE STATE, HUGE MIGRATORY
ISSUES AND ZONING IS CRITICAL TO
THAT. BUT MY QUESTION TO YOU IS
THAT IS AND I AND I SAID ON SUB
TWO, WHICH IS WHERE WE FUNDED
THE, THE WHEN WE HAD MONEY, THE
WILDLIFE CROSSINGS, DOWN IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA FOR LIONS,
QUITE FRANKLY, WHERE THERE WAS,
WHERE THERE WAS AN ISSUE. SO
WHERE YOU ALREADY HAVE
DEVELOPMENT, SEVERE DEVELOPMENT,
WHICH IS MAINLY THE COASTLINES
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA, WHAT IS
YOUR WHAT IS YOUR WHAT IS HOW IS
THIS CAN IMPACT AREAS WHERE IT'S
JUST VERY DIFFICULT ALREADY TO
FIGURE OUT THOSE CORRIDORS HAVE
BEEN RUINED, QUITE FRANKLY, BY
INTERSTATE FREEWAYS. AND SO
WHAT'S YOUR THOUGHT ON TRYING TO
MANAGE THOSE SMALL AREAS THAT
ARE LEFT IN VERY DEVELOPED
AREAS? WHAT IS HOW IS THAT THIS
BILL GOING TO IMPACT THAT? YEAH,
YOU KNOW, IT. THERE IS IN THIS
BILL IT DOESN'T CREATE ANY
PROGRAMS. IT DOESN'T IT DOESN'T.
AND I WOULD SAY SORT OF AS AN
ANSWER AS WELL TO THE OTHER
CONCERN THAT IT DOESN'T CREATE
ANY NEW BURDEN. IT'S NOT
CHANGING. ALL IT'S DOING IS
SAYING PLAN EARLIER FOR IT. THE
BURDEN IS THERE REGARDLESS WHEN
YOU DEVELOP IN TERMS OF THE
EXISTING AREAS, I THINK IT WOULD
BE GREAT IF THEY KNOW THEY HAVE
AN ISSUE AS WE HAVE IN LOS
ANGELES WITH SOME OF OUR BIG
CATS. WE NOW HAVE A NEW LION IN
GRIFFITH PARK TO USE THIS AS AN
EXCUSE OR AS A TIME WHEN WE CAN
START LOOKING AND MITIGATING
SOME OF THE EXISTING IMPACTS.
YOU KNOW, WE'VE HAD SOMETHING
LIKE NINE LIONS OR EIGHT LIONS
IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS KILLED ON
THE ONE ON THE ON THE FREEWAY.
THAT'S REALLY DANGEROUS FOR
HUMANS. THAT'S WHY WE'RE
BUILDING THE WILDLIFE CROSSING.
YOU KNOW, IF WE'RE DOING THIS
EVERY TEN YEARS, IT'S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR CITIES TO TAKE A
LOOK AT WHEN THEY'RE HAVING
TRAFFIC. YOU KNOW, THEY'RE
HAVING THESE TRAFFIC COLLISIONS
WHERE THEY'RE HAVING. AND I'VE
GOT PARTS OF MY DISTRICT WHERE
THERE'S BEARS BEING LIKE
AIRLIFTED OUT OF NEIGHBORHOODS,
YOU KNOW, ON A FAIRLY REGULAR
BASIS. IT SEEMS LIKE, YOU KNOW,
THESE ARE REALLY CAUSING A
PROBLEM IN COMMUNITIES. THIS
COULD BE A TIME TO LOOK AT, HEY,
IS THERE AN AREA WE CAN FENCE?
THE BEAUTY OF THIS IS THAT NOW
IT MAKES FISH AND WILDLIFE
AVAILABLE TO THE AGENCIES TO
CONSULT, WHEREAS RIGHT NOW THEY
DON'T REALLY HAVE THAT SAME
ACCESS. SO WE'VE HAD AGENCIES
TELL US, YOU KNOW, THIS ACTUALLY
COULD BE HELPFUL BECAUSE NOW WE
CAN GET DATA FROM THEM, WE CAN
GET INFORMATION FROM THEM, WE
CAN GET SUGGESTIONS. THERE'S NO
ENFORCEMENT IN THIS. NO ONE'S
GOING TO COME AND DING THEM IF
THEY'RE NOT DOING IT. I THINK IT
WOULD BE NICE IF THEY TOOK A
LOOK IF THEY KNOW THEY'RE HAVING
PROBLEMS, BUT THIS IS REALLY
MUCH MORE PERSPECTIVE. IT'S
ABOUT DEVELOPMENT IN THE FUTURE.
THAT'S WHAT IT'S AIMED AT NOT
NOT TRYING TO FIX THINGS THAT
ARE THERE NOW. OKAY. THANK YOU.
I JUST ONE LAST COMMENT. YOU
KNOW, WE HAD THE WILLIAMSON ACT,
WHICH WAS A LONGTIME BILL THAT
ALLOWED AGRICULTURE TO GET A TAX
EXEMPTION ON THEIR PROPERTY TAX,
A SMALL TAX EXEMPTION TO KEEP
OPEN SPACE. AND YOU HAD TO NOT
DEVELOP, BUT UNFORTUNATELY, IT
DOESN'T GET IT NEVER GETS FUNDED
. SO NOBODY USES THAT PROGRAM
ANYMORE. AS AG, WE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO KEEP SOME OPEN
SPACE IN AREAS AND ACTUALLY KILL
IT AND MAKE A LIVING OFF IT.
ANYWAY, I'M GOING TO LAY OFF
YOUR BILL TODAY. I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THE AMENDMENTS THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT MAKING SATISFYING.
SO WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
IT GETS OUT OF COMMITTEE AND
ONTO THE FLOOR. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. OKAY, ANY CLOSING REMARKS?
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION.
WE'RE DEFINITELY LISTENING WITH
OUR EARS OPEN. AND WE'LL DO OUR
BEST TO ADDRESS THE CONCERNS.
GREAT. WHEN WE GET OUR QUORUM,
WE WILL TAKE UP THE VOTE ON THIS
NEXT, ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN
IS AB 20 553. THANK YOU. I'M
HALFWAY THROUGH, PROUD TO
PRESENT AB 2253. WE WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE SUGGESTED
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ON PAGE FOR
COMMENT. THREE OF THE ANALYSIS.
AND AGAIN, I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE AND THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THE
BILL. AB 2553 CLARIFIES REYES
WHEN LOCAL JURISDICTIONS MUST
IMPOSE LOWER TRAFFIC IMPACT FEES
ON TRANSIT, PROXIMATE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS. IT ALSO UPDATES
THE DEFINITION OF MAJOR TRANSIT
STOP TO REFLECT POST-COVID
SERVICE LEVELS, FIRST, IF A
LOCAL AGENCY HAS ADOPTED A
TRAFFIC IMPACT FEE, THE
MITIGATION FEE ACT REQUIRES THE
FEE TO BE SET AT A LOWER RATE
FOR HOUSING DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS
THAT GENERATE REDUCED VEHICLE
TRIPS. AS DETERMINED BY WHETHER
THE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT MEETS
SEVERAL CRITERIA, INCLUDING
PROXIMITY TO TRANSIT. CURRENTLY,
THE LAW REQUIRES HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS BE WITHIN ONE HALF
MILE OF A TRANSIT STATION, WHICH
IS A VERY NARROW AND OLD
FASHIONED DEFINITION THAT
EXCLUDES MANY PROJECTS WELL
SERVED BY TRANSIT, MANY LOCAL
AGENCIES HAVE VERY HIGH TRAFFIC
IMPACT FEES, POSING AN
IMPEDIMENT TO THE PRODUCTION OF
HOUSING AND OVERCHARGING.
TRANSIT. PROXIMATE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS THAT WOULD HAVE
MINIMAL TRAFFIC IMPACTS.
HOWEVER, SEVERAL OTHER STATUTES,
INCLUDING THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ACT AND
THE STATE DENSITY BONUS LAW,
ENCOURAGED DEVELOPMENT TO OCCUR
NEAR TRANSIT BY PROVIDING
BENEFITS SUCH AS A STREAMLINED
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW AND LOWER
PARKING STANDARDS, AMONGST
OTHERS. UNDER THESE STATUTES, A
DEVELOPMENT PROJECT MUST BE
PROXIMATE TO A MAJOR TRANSIT
STOP, WHICH, AMONG OTHER THINGS,
INCLUDES THE INTERSECTION OF TWO
OR MORE MAJOR BUS ROUTES WITH A
FREQUENCY OF 15 MINUTES OR LESS
DURING MORNING AND AFTERNOON
PEAK PERIODS, AND AB 2553
REQUIRES THE AGENCIES TO
CONSIDER REDUCING REDUCING
TRAFFIC IMPACT FEES FOR HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS WITHIN A HALF MILE
OF MAJOR TRANSIT STOPS TO
CONFORM THE LANGUAGE, AND THE
INTENT BEHIND THESE DEFINITIONS,
AND BECAUSE SOME TRANSIT
AGENCIES CUT THEIR SERVICE TIME
BECAUSE OF COVID 19, THERE ARE
FEWER LOCATIONS THAT ARE MEETING
THE DEFINITION OF A MAJOR
TRANSIT STOP. HOWEVER, WE STILL
KNOW THAT PEOPLE ARE WRITING
TRANSIT AND THAT PROJECTS CLOSE
TO TRANSIT DO REDUCE THE NEED
FOR PEOPLE TO BE DRIVING AROUND.
AND WE SHOULD GIVE THOSE
PROJECTS THE SAME BENEFIT THAT
THEY USED TO RECEIVE POST
PRE-COVID. SPEAKING IN SUPPORT
OF AB 2553 TODAY IS MICHAEL
LANE, STATE POLICY DIRECTOR FOR
SPUR. THIS BILL HAS HAD
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT, NO
OPPOSITION, AND HAS GOTTEN NO NO
VOTES. SO WITH THAT, I WOULD
REQUEST WE CONTINUE THE TREND.
THANKS THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MADAM CHAIR. GO AHEAD. GO AHEAD.
MR. LANE. MICHAEL AND WHISPER,
PUBLIC POLICY THINK TANK IN THE
SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA. AND WE
REALLY DO SEE THIS LEGISLATION
AS BUILDING ON THE STATE'S
POLICIES, PLANS AND FUNDING
PRIORITIES, PARTICULARLY FOR
TRANSIT ORIENTED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING, AND TO CREATE MORE
OPPORTUNITIES AND INCENTIVES TO
BE ABLE TO BUILD THAT TYPE OF
HOUSING AND TO ALSO HELP TO
BOOST TRANSIT RIDERSHIP. SO I
THINK IT REALLY TIES IN WITH ALL
OF OUR OTHER GOALS, INCLUDING
EQUITY, AFFORDABILITY AND
SUSTAINABILITY IN TERMS OF
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY. SO WE
URGENTLY ASK YOUR SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT OF AB 2553? RAFA
SONNENFELD WITH M ACTION AND IN
THE INTEREST OF BREVITY, I WON'T
LIST THE NEARLY TWO DOZEN
CHAPTERS THAT ARE ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU TWICE FOR
MEETING WITH LIGHTHOUSE PUBLIC
AFFAIRS. I'M HERE IN SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF SAND HILL PROPERTIES,
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA
AND CIVIC WELL, THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. NINA HARWELL WITH AARP
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
. GOOD MORNING, BROOKE PRITCHARD
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA YIMBY IN
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING, MARK
VUKOVICH. I'M A HALF A STREETS
FOR ALL IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
OKAY. ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO AB
2553 OKAY. SEEING NONE. YES
CLOSING REMARKS. OH, NO. OH,
SORRY. SENATOR DOLLY, ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS? OKAY. ALL
RIGHT. SEEING NO MORE. NO MORE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS YOU'D LIKE
TO CLOSE. I APPRECIATE THE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
OKAY OKAY. AND YOUR LAST BILL IS
AB 2712. YES. I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS BY COMPLETELY
ELIMINATING SECTION 6586 3.2.1 C
OF THE BILL. I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE AND COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR WORK ON WORK ON THIS
BILL. THIS IS A DISTRICT BILL
THAT ONLY APPLIES TO THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES AND WHAT THIS BILL
WILL DO IS IN AREAS WHERE MY
PREVIOUS BILL THAT REMOVED A
CITY'S ABILITY TO REQUIRE
MANDATED PARKING NEAR TRANSIT,
WE HAVE HAD A PROBLEM IN SOME OF
OUR MOST DENSE AREAS WHERE
DEVELOPERS ARE COMING IN WITH
VERY LARGE MARKET RATE PROJECTS,
AND THEY ARE PROMISING EVERYBODY
THAT THEY WILL HAVE PERMIT
PARKING FOR THE NEIGHBORHOODS
BEHIND THEM BECAUSE SOME OF
THESE CORRIDORS WERE ACTUALLY
NEVER ZONED FOR HOUSING IN THE
PAST. AND SO THEY WERE SORT OF
LOOPED INTO PREFERENTIAL PARKING
ZONES BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T HAVE
HOUSING. THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
SORT OF DREW A LINE DOWN SOME OF
OUR MAJOR CORRIDORS, LIKE
WILSHIRE BOULEVARD AND OLYMPIC,
BECAUSE AT THE TIME, THOSE WERE
ALL OFFICE BUILDINGS AND RETAIL.
AND SO NOW DEVELOPERS ARE COMING
IN AND BUILDING THESE LARGE,
BUILDING LARGE BUILDINGS AND
SAYING THEY'RE GOING TO TRY TO
GIVE EVERYBODY IN THE BUILDING 2
OR 3 PREFERENTIAL PARKING PASSES
IN AREAS WHERE THE EXISTING
NEIGHBORHOODS CANNOT ABSORB THAT
KIND OF IMPACT. AND AS THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL THAT DID GET
RID OF THOSE PARKING
REQUIREMENTS, THE IDEA WAS THAT
DEVELOPERS WOULD BUILD THE
PARKING THAT THEIR THAT THEIR
PROJECTS REALLY NEEDED AND THAT
IF PEOPLE WERE GOING TO MOVE
INTO A UNIT THAT DIDN'T HAVE
PARKING, THEY WERE GOING TO
SELF-SELECT IN BASED ON THEIR
ABILITY TO RIDE TRANSIT OR TO
WALK TO WORK. NOT THAT THEY WERE
GOING TO ADD IMPACT TO THE
NEIGHBORHOOD SURROUNDING IT. SO
AB 2712 WILL EXEMPT RESIDENTS.
THERE ARE SOME EXEMPTIONS. IT
EXEMPTS RESIDENTS AND
RESIDENTIAL DEVELOPMENTS THAT
ARE 20 UNITS OR LESS. SO IT
WON'T STOP PEOPLE FROM ADDING A
COUPLE OF UNITS TO AN EXISTING
BUILDING BECAUSE WE NEED THAT.
IT EXEMPTS THE RESIDENTS AND
UNITS THAT ARE DEED RESTRICTED
DEVELOPMENTS INTENDED FOR
HOUSEHOLDS THAT ARE VERY LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS, EXTREMELY LOW
INCOME OR LOWER INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS. IT ALLOWS THE CITY
TO, IT, SO THIS IS A BILL THAT,
YOU KNOW, IS REALLY TO, TRY TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE UNINTENDED
IMPACTS OF MY PREVIOUS BILL. AB
2097. IT IS LIMITED TO THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES, AND IT'S
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
SPEAKING TODAY IN SUPPORT IS
NATALIE BROWN WITH THE PLANNING
AND CONSERVATION LEAGUE. AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR. I
VOTE MISS BROWN. GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR GIARRUSSO
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS NATALIE BROWN WITH THE
PLANNING AND CONSERVATION
LEAGUE. AND I'M HERE TODAY TO
SECOND WHAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN HAS SAID AND TO EXPRESS
CALIFORNIA'S NEED FOR THE SMART
AND RESPONSIBLE PARKING REFORMS
PUT FORTH IN AB 2712, THIS BILL
RECOGNIZES THE NEED TO SUPPORT
TRANSIT ORIENTED DEVELOPMENT AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WITHOUT
ENCROACHING ON AND OVERCROWDING
THE CURB CURB PARKING THAT
EXISTING RESIDENTS RELY ON BY
EXCLUDING LARGE, LOW AND NO
PARKING DEVELOPMENTS FROM
PREFERENTIAL PARKING DISTRICTS
IN LOS ANGELES. AB 2712 WILL ONE
PREVENT INFILL DEVELOPMENT FROM
DISPLACING NEIGHBORS FROM THE
CURB PARKING THEY CURRENTLY RELY
ON? TWO IT WILL DIFFUSE
OPPOSITION TO NEW HOUSING AND
BUSINESSES ON THE GROUNDS THAT
THEY WILL OVERCROWD NEARBY
STREET PARKING, MAKING IT EASIER
TO GET THESE PROJECTS OFF THE
GROUND. AND THREE, IT WILL
ENSURE THAT TRANSIT ORIENTED
DEVELOPMENT IS ACTUALLY TRANSIT
ORIENTED. THESE PROJECTS SHOULD
SUPPORT CAR FREE TENANTS AND
CUSTOMERS, NOT SIMPLY PUSH
PARKING DEMANDS TO ALREADY
CROWDED STREETS. AB 2712 IS A
WIN FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING, FOR
EXISTING NEIGHBORS, AND FOR
CLIMATE AND PUBLIC HEALTH GOALS.
WE KNOW THAT CALIFORNIA CANNOT
MEET ITS LONG TERM CLIMATE GOALS
WITHOUT REFORMING OUR LAND USE
PATTERNS. TO CURB VMT GROWTH, WE
KNOW THAT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
WON'T TRULY BE AFFORDABLE AS
LONG AS LOW WAGE HOUSEHOLDS ARE
DISPLACED TO THE URBAN PERIPHERY
AND PRICED OUT OF TRANSIT,
ACCESS AND PROXIMITY TO ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES WE WEAR, TRANSIT
IS AN OPTION. WE KNOW THAT
MANDATORY PARKING MINIMUMS
IMPOSE ARTIFICIALLY INFLATED
PRICES ON RESIDENTS. THEY DO NOT
NEED, AND POTENTIALLY CANNOT
AFFORD BY ADDRESSING CONCERNS
ABOUT REMOVING PARKING MINIMUMS
AND REDUCING OPPOSITION TO
NEARBY LOW INCOME HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT, THIS BILL FOSTERS
INCLUSIVE AND RESILIENT
COMMUNITIES AND BY CURBING URBAN
SPRAWL AND INDUCED CAR USAGE,
THIS BILL CONTRIBUTES TO
REDUCTIONS IN VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED, THEREBY REDUCING AIR
POLLUTION, MITIGATING GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS, AND ADVANCING
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE GOALS,
WHICH IS A WIN FOR EVERYONE. AB
2712 IS AN INCREDIBLY CREATIVE
AND INCREDIBLY PRAGMATIC
APPROACH TO OUR CLIMATE AND
HOUSING CRISIS THAT SUPPORTS
BOTH EQUITY AND EXISTING
COMMUNITY NEEDS. THIS BILL IS
IMPORTANT AND THOUGHTFUL, AND I
URGE YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT OF AB 2712? NÓ SEEING
NONE, ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO AB
2712. OKAY, GREAT. ALL RIGHT.
SENATOR. WELL, I JUST GOD, THIS
IS A TOUGH ONE FOR ME BECAUSE.
THE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF
TRYING TO DO INFILL AROUND
TRANSIT IS YOU STILL THE PUBLIC
IS STILL DRIVING CARS.
UNFORTUNATELY, WE'RE NOT GOING
TO. WE'RE THE POLICIES HAVE BEEN
PUSHING THEM TOWARDS GETTING OUT
OF VEHICLES BECAUSE WE'RE GOING
TO SAVE THE WORLD, CLIMATE WISE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. BUT AT THE
END OF THE DAY, IT'S REALLY NOT
HAPPENING ON THE STREET. IT'S
NOT HAPPENING. PEOPLE STILL HAVE
CARS AND THEY'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO LIVE IN THIS
LOW INCOME HOUSING NEXT TO A
TRANSIT. BUT THEY STILL HAVE A
CAR. SO WHAT ARE THEY DOING?
THEY'RE PARKING NEXT TO IT IN
SOMEBODY ELSE'S LOT OR SOMEWHERE
. AND IT'S THIS IS THE PROBLEM.
AND SO IF YOU DON'T ADDRESS
PARKING. YOU'RE STILL GOING TO
HAVE TICKED OFF NEIGHBORS AND
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE. AND IF YOU
DON'T HAVE A DESIGNATED SPOT,
SOMEBODY IS GOING TO TAKE YOUR
SPOT. AND I MEAN, I WAS IN SAN
FRANCISCO JUST THE OTHER DAY,
I'M SORRY. THE OTHER THE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO IS NOT HERE. I
COULDN'T FIND A PARKING SPOT.
IT'S LIKE LITERALLY NO PARKING.
WELL, I HAVE A MEETING TO GO TO
OR A ACTUALLY, IT WAS A MEDICAL
MEETING, AND IT'S LIKE I IT WAS
MILES BEFORE I COULD FIND A
PLACE TO PARK. SO HOW IS THIS
GOING TO. THIS IS ONLY FOR LOS
ANGELES, BUT THERE'S A STATEWIDE
PROBLEM WHEN YOU DO INFILL. I
MEAN, RIGHT HERE ON FOLSOM
BOULEVARD, THEY DID INFILL RIGHT
NEXT TO THE LIGHT RAIL STATION,
AND IT'S THERE'S A LOT OF LITTLE
SCOOTERS THERE, BUT THERE'S
STILL CARS EVERYWHERE. SO I'M
JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT I
MEAN, I KNOW YOUR PREVIOUS BILL,
I KNOW YOU'RE TRYING TO FIX IT,
BUT YOU'RE NOT FIXING IT FOR
EVERYBODY. AND THEN WE HAVE TO
HAVE AN ADULT CONVERSATION ABOUT
PARKING, BECAUSE CALIFORNIANS
ARE NOT MOVING FAST ENOUGH OUT
OF THEIR CARS TO MITIGATE THE
HOUSING ISSUE WE HAVE. SO, YEAH,
AND JUST TO BE CLEAR, WE'VE
ALREADY GOTTEN AWAY WITH THE
PARKING MANDATE. SO DEVELOPERS
ARE STILL FREE TO BUILD PARKING
ON THEIR SITES IF THEY FEEL THAT
THEIR TENANTS ARE GOING TO NEED
THE PARKING, THEY CAN STILL
PROVIDE THAT. AND WHAT'S IRONIC
IS THAT THIS BILL IS IN RESPONSE
TO MARKET RATE DEVELOPERS WHO
ARE BUILDING, NOT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS WHO ARE JUST
NOT WANTING TO PAY FOR THAT
SUBTERRANEAN PARKING. THESE ARE
AREAS WHERE IF YOU GAVE ALL
THESE PEOPLE PERMITS, YOU'RE
STILL NOT CREATING ANY MORE CURB
PARKING. SO THAT IS NOT A
SOLUTION. SO WE HAVE A CHOICE.
THE CHOICE IS WE DON'T BUILD IN
THESE AREAS AT ALL. AND WE KEEP
PUSHING PEOPLE FURTHER AND
FURTHER AWAY FROM THESE URBAN
CENTERS WHERE THEIR JOBS ARE.
THAT'S ONE SOLUTION. THAT'S WHAT
WE'VE BASICALLY BEEN DOING. OR
WE CAN MAKE THE INVESTMENTS IN
MASS TRANSIT THAT WE REALLY NEED
TO MAKE WHILE STILL ALLOWING FOR
BUILDING, YOU KNOW, OTHER CITIES
THAT HAVE DEVELOPED HAVE FIGURED
THIS OUT, WHETHER IT'S, YOU
KNOW, I WAS JUST IN WASHINGTON,
DC, AND I DIDN'T HAVE A CAR IN
WASHINGTON, D.C. I TOOK THE BUS
AND I TOOK TRANSIT EVERYWHERE,
AND IT WAS GLORIOUS. YOU KNOW,
THERE'S THERE THERE ARE WAYS
THAT CITIES CAN MITIGATE. I HAD
ANOTHER BILL THAT PASSED LAST
YEAR THAT ALLOWS FOR DEVELOPERS
TO SHARE PARKING. DEVELOPERS CAN
CONTRACT FOR PARKING WITH. AND
WE'VE SEEN THIS ALREADY IN LOS
ANGELES. WE HAVE A LOT OF OFFICE
BUILDINGS THAT ARE LACKING
TENANTS RIGHT NOW AND HAVE GIANT
PARKING SPACES UNDERNEATH. WE
ARE SEEING SOME HOUSING
DEVELOPERS LEASING OUT THOSE
PARKING LOTS AS PARKING SPACES
AND LETTING PEOPLE PARK IN THAT
BUILDING. THAT ONE IS 1 OR 2
BUILDINGS OVER. SO WHEN YOU WHEN
YOU REALLY, YOU KNOW, NEED TO
USE THIS RESOURCE, CITIES CAN
FIGURE OUT WAYS TO DO IT. I'LL
TELL YOU CITY, MY DISTRICT
OFFICES, MY DISTRICT OFFICE IS
IN A BUILDING THAT HAS A GIANT
ABOVE GROUND PARKING LOT THAT'S
TAKING UP A LOT OF SPACE. THERE
IS LESS THAN ONE FLOOR OF THAT
USE AT ANY GIVEN TIME. AT THE
PEAK OF THE OF THE OFFICE DAY,
HALF A FLOOR, MAYBE. AND IT'S
GOT ANOTHER SIX FLOORS ABOVE.
IT'S A COMPLETE WASTE OF SPACE
AT THIS POINT. AND YET WHEN THE
CITY WANTED TO DEVELOP A HOUSING
UNIT IN THE DOWNTOWN, YOU KNOW
WHAT THEY TRIED TO DO? GET THAT
DEVELOPER TO ADD A WHOLE BUNCH
OF SUBTERRANEAN PARKING. SO
THERE ARE THERE ARE REASONS THAT
WE NEED TO PUSH CITIES AND, AND
DEVELOPERS TO ALSO USE THE
RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE MORE
WISELY AND MAKE THOSE
INVESTMENTS INTO THE TRANSIT
THAT WILL ALLOW US TO BUILD.
BECAUSE JUST BECAUSE WE BUILD
THE HOUSING, EVEN IF YOU BUILD
IT WITH THE PARKING, YOU'RE NOW
ADDING SO MUCH CONGESTION THAT
PEOPLE CAN'T EVEN GET AROUND IN
A LOT OF OUR AREAS. SO WE HAVE
GOT WE CAN'T JUST SAY, HEY, GIVE
THEM THE PARKING PERMITS.
PROBLEM SOLVED. AS MY WITNESS
SAID, YOU NEED TO. WE NEED TO BE
THINKING OF OTHER WAYS TO, TO DO
MOBILITY AND BETTER WAYS TO DO
MOBILITY. MANY CITIES AROUND THE
WORLD HAVE FIGURED THIS OUT. WE
NEED TO DO I'M TALKING ABOUT LOS
ANGELES SPECIFICALLY NOW. WE
NEED TO DO A MUCH BETTER JOB.
BUT WE KNOW THAT BRINGING MORE
CARS INTO THESE AREAS IS THE
OPPOSITE OF WHAT WE NEED TO DO.
ALL WE'RE DOING IS ADDING
CONGESTION AND ADDING TO THE
PARKING PROBLEM. SO I WE CAN'T
FIGURE IT ALL OUT IN ONE BILL.
BUT I KNOW THAT DOING THIS WILL
ACTUALLY HELP THE PROBLEM AND
NOT TO CONTINUE TO EXACERBATE
AND MAKE IT TO THE POINT WHERE
THESE RESIDENTS WHO LIVE NEARBY
WILL OPPOSE THE HOUSING THAT WE
DESPERATELY NEED IN THESE AREAS,
DESPERATELY NEED IT. THANK YOU
SO THANK YOU. WELL, I WANT TO
JUST FOLLOW BECAUSE WE TALK
ABOUT TRANSIT AND THAT'S PEOPLE
AREN'T RIDING TRANSIT. I MEAN,
IT'S ANOTHER PROBLEM. I SIT ON
THE TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE AND
TRANSIT IS A BIG ISSUE TOO. AND
IT'S NOT JUST IT'S THEY'RE
TRYING TO DO A BILL IN SAN
FRANCISCO TO JUST FUND THEIR
TRANSIT THERE BECAUSE PEOPLE
AREN'T RIDING IT. SO. SO WHAT?
SO I MEAN, IT'S JUST LIKE EVERY
OPTION WE HAVE IS NOT WORKING
WHEN WE'RE TRYING TO CROWD
PEOPLE IN WHICH, WHICH WHICH IS
VERY FRUSTRATING. I GUESS FOR ME
IT'S LIKE WE WANT TO TAX THE
PEOPLE FOR MORE MONEY, TO GO
BUILD TRANSIT WHEN PEOPLE AREN'T
EVEN RIDING THE TRANSIT AS IT
IS. SO I'M. THANK YOU, WELL, IN
LOS ANGELES, OUR RIDERSHIP IS
GROWING. AND SO THERE'S
SOMETHING THAT'S ATTRACTING MORE
PEOPLE. UNFORTUNATELY, SOMETIMES
THEY'RE FORCED BECAUSE OF THE
COST OF GASOLINE AND OTHER OTHER
THINGS. THAT SHOULD NOT BE THE
REASON. BUT WE KNOW THAT TRANSIT
RIDERSHIP IS GROWING. SO IT'S AS
THE AUTHOR SAYS, THIS IS NOT THE
WHOLE PICTURE. AND WE HAVE TO DO
A NUMBER OF THINGS ALL AT THE
SAME TIME. OKAY. THANK YOU, NO
MORE QUESTIONS. DO YOU WANT
FINAL FINAL WORDS ON YOUR FINAL
BILL? I APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION AND ABSOLUTELY AGREE
THAT WE NEED TO MAKE TRANSIT
BETTER, INVESTED IN A BETTER WAY
TO INVEST IN IT SO THAT MORE
PEOPLE WANT TO RIDE IT THE WAY
THEY DO IN OTHER CITIES THAT
HAVE EXCELLENT TRANSIT. THANK
YOU. AND WE WILL BE TAKING UP
WHEN WE GET A QUORUM. THANK YOU.
SPEAK UP. ALL FOUR BILLS. THANK
YOU, NEXT WE HAVE, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHAU AB 1820. AND IF YOU
HAVE A WITNESS, OKAY.
GOOD MORNING. GOOD MORNING,
MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS, I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT THE AB 1820 TO YOU. THIS
IS A SIMPLE, GOOD GOVERNMENT
MEASURE THAT ALLOWS HOUSING
DEVELOPERS TO NÓ DEVELOPMENT
FEES PRIOR TO COMMITTING SHOVELS
TO GROUND IN 2021, A STUDY
CONDUCTED BY THE TERNER CENTER
FOR HOUSING INNOVATION AT UC
BERKELEY FOUND INCONSISTENT
COMPLIANCE WITH AB 1483, WHICH
REQUIRED CITIES AND COUNTIES TO
POST THE FEE SCHEDULE TO THEIR
WEBSITES. MANY JURISDICTIONS HAD
INCOMPLETE, UNRELIABLE FEES OR
HARD TO FIND INFORMATION.
KNOWLEDGE OF THESE FEES ARE
CRITICAL BECAUSE THESE FEES CAN
ADD UP TO 20% OF THE COST OF A
HOME, WHICH CAN BE THE TIPPING
POINT FOR MANY PEOPLE IN HAVING
IS IN BEING ABLE TO ACCESS AN
AFFORDABLE HOME. AB 1820
PROVIDES GUARDRAILS, ESPECIALLY
FOR AFFORDABLE HOME DEVELOPERS,
TO HAVE PREDICTABILITY OF COSTS
AFFILIATED WITH THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THAT WE NEED SO URGENTLY
. ARE THESE THE RECENT AUTHOR
AMENDMENTS REMOVED ALL
OPPOSITION. WE APPRECIATE
WORKING WITH COMMITTEE STAFF,
THESE AMENDMENTS WERE TECHNICAL
AND PROVIDE BETTER CLARITY. CSAK
CAL FIRE CHIEFS AND THE LEAGUE
ALONG WITH PARK AND SPECIAL
DISTRICTS WERE INSTRUMENTAL IN
THESE DISCUSSIONS AND I WANT TO
THANK ALL OF THE STAKEHOLDERS,
STAKEHOLDERS IN THIS PROCESS AND
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. I
HAVE MICHAEL LANE FROM SPUR AND
WES. IS WES HERE TO WES? WES IS
HERE TO WES. SAGE WALKER, A
LOCAL SACRAMENTO DEVELOPERS.
ALSO HERE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS MICHAEL
SPURR, PUBLIC POLICY THINK TANK
IN THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA.
WE REALLY SEE THIS AS THE BILLS
PREMISE TO BE NO SURPRISES. WE
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT FOR
DEVELOPERS TO BE ABLE TO ENGAGE
EARLY WITH THE LOCAL
JURISDICTION TO IDENTIFY WHAT
THOSE FEES MIGHT BE, BECAUSE
THEY CAN BE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
AND UP TO NEARLY 20% OF THE COST
OF A NEW HOUSING UNIT. AND TO
CATCH ANY ERRORS AND OMISSIONS
EARLY IN THE PROCESS, IF THEY DO
EXIST, OR ANY MISUNDERSTANDINGS,
IS TO HOPEFULLY AVOID ANY KINDS
OF CONFLICTS OR EVEN POTENTIAL
LITIGATION, WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER ANYONE ELSE HERE ON IN
SUPPORT? GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING.
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. AND
COUNCIL AND, MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, MY NAME IS WESLEY
SAGE WALKER. I'M WITH GATEWAY
DEVELOPMENT COMPANY. WE'VE GOT
OVER A THOUSAND UNITS, IN OUR
PIPELINE IN THE SACRAMENTO AREA.
PRINCIPALLY FOCUS ON MULTIFAMILY
, WITH PRIVATELY FINANCED,
AFFORDABLE HOUSING COMPONENT TO
IT. SO NOT NOT TAKING ANY PUBLIC
SUBSIDIES, BUT STILL MANAGING TO
CREATE A, YOU KNOW, DEED
RESTRICTED UNITS, WHICH IS, I
THINK, A COOL THING, AND SO,
REALLY, I'M JUST HERE BECAUSE,
YOU KNOW, THE JOB FUNDAMENTALLY
OF A REAL ESTATE DEVELOPER IS TO
DO RISK MITIGATION AND TO HANDLE
RISK, THERE ARE A LOT OF
DIFFERENT BUCKETS OF RISK, BUT
ONE NON-TRIVIAL, SOURCE OF RISK
IS IMPACT FEES. WHEN WE GO IN TO
SUBMIT A PROJECT, OFTEN WE ARE
ARE REALLY JUST TRYING TO BASE
OUR GUESSES ON WHAT THAT'S GOING
TO BE BASED ON PAST PROJECTS,
AND THEN OBVIOUSLY WE'LL GO TO
THEIR TO THEIR TABLES AND TRY
AND DO SOME OF OUR OWN
CALCULATIONS. BUT, IT'S NOT
ALWAYS, OUR, OUR CALCULATIONS DO
NOT ALWAYS LINE UP, WITH, WITH
THE NUMBERS THAT WE'RE PRESENTED
FROM THE CITY, PARTICULARLY WHEN
IT COMES TO ANY SORT OF OFF SITE
REQUIREMENTS, THAT COME DOWN THE
COME DOWN THE PIPELINE FROM
VARIOUS AGENCIES, AS STATED,
THESE IMPACT FEES DO CONTRIBUTE
A NON-TRIVIAL AMOUNT OF THE COST
PER UNIT. AND SO THE VARIATION
THAT YOU CAN SEE FROM
JURISDICTION TO JURISDICTION AND
FROM, FRANKLY, PROJECT TYPE TO
PROJECT TYPE, CAN REALLY BE A
REAL SOURCE OF RISK, AND SO I
THINK HAVING GREATER CLARITY ON
THAT EARLIER IN THE PROCESS IS A
WAY FOR US TO HELP REDUCE RISK
ON PROJECTS WHICH, YOU KNOW,
WOULD HELP MORE PROJECTS MOVE
FORWARD, FINALLY, THE MAIN
BENEFIT I SEE HERE IS THAT I
THINK THAT THIS CAN HELP
INCREASE MARKET COMPETITIVENESS,
PARTICULARLY IF YOU'RE IF YOU'RE
AN ESTABLISHED DEVELOPER, YOU
COULD WRAP UP, PLEASE, IF YOU'RE
ESTABLISHED DEVELOPMENT FIRM,
YOU CAN MORE EASILY GO INTO
OTHER JURISDICTIONS. AND IF
YOU'RE A NEW DEVELOPER, THIS IS
INFORMATION THAT YOU WOULDN'T
NECESSARILY KNOW. SO THANK YOU
MUCH. THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF AB 1820.
YES, MADAM CHAIR MICHAEL
GUNNING, LIGHTHOUSE PUBLIC
AFFAIRS HERE IN SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION,
SAND HILL PROPERTIES AND BUCKEYE
PROPERTIES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. AND HOW MANY DAYS IS ALSO WITH
LIGHTHOUSE PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON
BEHALF OF HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIA AND CIVIC WELL, THANK
YOU. RAFA SONNENFELD WITH THE
NBA ACTION IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
, CATHERINE CHARLES, ON BEHALF
OF BROWNSTEIN, ON BEHALF OF
HOUSING ACTION COALITION,
HOUSING CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT,
BROOKE PRITCHARD ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA YIMBY IS A PROUD
CO-SPONSOR. THANK YOU SIR. THAT
SOUND THERE OKAY, ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB 1820? OKAY YES.
COME UP TO THE MIC. GOOD
MORNING. CHAIR MEMBERS, ANTHONY
TANNEHILL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION. I
WANTED TO INFORM EVERYONE THAT
WE'VE MOVED FROM OPPOSITION TO
NEUTRALITY AND KIND OF AN OSCARS
ACCEPTANCE SPEECH HERE, THANKS
TO THE AUTHOR AND HER STAFF AND
THE PROPONENTS AND ALL THE OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS. IT WAS A LOT OF
HARD WORK, AND WE'RE REALLY
APPRECIATIVE OF IT. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
MEMBERS. BRADY GIRTON, ON BEHALF
OF THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES, ALSO MOVING TO NEUTRAL
ON THIS BILL. APPRECIATE ALL THE
CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD ON THE
GOOD WORK BY STAFF AND THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
LIKEWISE ALYSSA SALEHI WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RECREATION AND PARK DISTRICTS,
THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE AND SPONSORS
CAME TOGETHER AND WORKED REALLY
HARD WITH US, AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
GO NEUTRAL. THANK YOU. JULIE
MALINOWSKI ON BEHALF OF THE,
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION AND THE FIRE
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA, MOVING TO NEUTRAL.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. OKAY.
SEEING NO ONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION, SENATOR, GREAT.
BILL, I LIKE TRANSPARENCY. I
THINK IT'S A GOOD IDEA TO LET
PEOPLE KNOW AHEAD OF TIME, AND,
AND PEOPLE WHO HAVE DEVELOPED OR
NOT DEVELOPED THESE DEVELOPERS
KNOW, BUT WHEN YOU'RE TRYING TO
PUT AN ADU IN, A LOT OF PEOPLE
ARE TRYING TO PUT AN ADUS IN
THEIR BACKYARD, AND THEY'RE
FINDING OUT THAT IT COSTS A LOT
OF MONEY TO HOOK UP TO THE SEWER
SYSTEM. AND THEY SHOULD KNOW
THAT IN ADVANCE. AND IF THERE'S,
IMPACT FEES TO SCHOOLS AND SUCH,
THEN THEN THEY SHOULD KNOW THAT.
SO I'LL BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL
WHEN WE GET A QUORUM. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. ANY CLOSING REMARKS?
YOU DON'T HAVE TO, BUT IF YOU
WANT TO, NO. JUST RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU. AND WE WILL
BE TAKING UP THE VOTE WHEN WE
GET OUR QUORUM. THANK YOU.
NHIÀU. A LITTLE BIT OF A BREAK.
RECESS. WAITING FOR OUR
PRESENTERS.
MR. MCCARTY IS MISSING OUT.
THANK YOU. OKAY. WELCOME.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ORTEGA, WE'RE
HERE TO HEAR FROM YOU ON AB
2557. YEP. AND THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
AB 2557 TODAY, I WILL BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND THANK YOUR STAFF
FOR ALL THEIR DILIGENT WORK WITH
MY TEAM. I MUST SAY THAT IN
PREPARING FOR TODAY AND THIS
BILL IN PARTICULARLY, I HAVE
BEEN REALLY SHOCKED AT THE
AMOUNT OF PUSHBACK THAT THIS
SIMPLE REPORTING AND
TRANSPARENCY BILL HAS RECEIVED,
ESPECIALLY FROM OUR NON SECTOR,
COMMUNITY. I GREW UP IN THE CITY
OF OAKLAND, WHERE NONPROFITS
WERE ESSENTIAL TO CHILDREN WHO
LOOK LIKE ME. AND IF IT WASN'T
FOR THE NONPROFITS, I WOULDN'T
BE HERE TODAY AS YOUR STATE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, WHICH IS WHY
IT'S BEEN SO SHOCKING TO HEAR
AND SEE THE OPPOSITIONS LETTERS
AND COMMENTS THROUGHOUT THIS
PROCESS. IN FACT, IN LOOKING AT
SEVEN OF THE EXECUTIVES WHO
SIGNED THE NONPROFIT OPPOSITION
LETTER, IT WAS BROUGHT TO MY
ATTENTION THAT MANY OF THEM MAKE
UPWARDS OF OVER 200,000 PER
YEAR. SOME MAKE EVEN MORE THAN
300,000, WHILE MANY OF THEIR
STAFF ARE IN LINE FOR SERVICES
THAT WE PROVIDE IN THE NONPROFIT
SECTOR, AS THIS BILL DOES
REQUIRE THAT PUBLIC CONTRACTS
ARE PUBLICLY POSTED ONLINE AND
THAT THEY INCLUDE THE CONTRACT
OBJECTIVES AND THE SALARIES AND
PAY SCALES FOR THE CONTRACTED
WORKFORCE. SENATOR, AS LAWMAKERS
, WE HAVE THE RIGHT TO KNOW WHAT
OUR TAXPAYERS MONEYS ARE GOING
FOR AND MAKING SURE THAT THE
RESULTS THAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR
ARE ACHIEVED. AND SO THIS BILL
SIMPLY DOES THAT. IT IS A
TRANSPARENCY BILL THAT ENSURES
THAT WE ARE HELD ACCOUNTABLE TO
OUR TAXPAYERS AND THAT WE ARE
ABLE TO SEE THAT WE ARE
DELIVERING RESULTS TODAY,
WITNESSES ON IN SUPPORT OF MY
BILL ARE BRIAN MIRAMONTES WITH
AFSCME AND IVANKA GRILLO WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION.
GOOD MORNING. GO AHEAD, GOOD.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
BRIAN MIRAMONTES WITH THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE,
COUNTY MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES. WE
REPRESENT OVER 200,000 PUBLIC
SERVICE WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND WE ARE PROUD CO-SPONSORS OF
AB 2557. IT IS NO SECRET THAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
INCREASINGLY RELYING ON PRIVATE
CONTRACTORS TO PROVIDE GOODS AND
SERVICES TRADITIONALLY PROVIDED
BY THE PUBLIC SECTOR WORKFORCE,
WHILE OUR MEMBERS SEE RAMPANT
CONTRACTING OUT OF PUBLIC
SERVICES, FROM FOSTER CARE TO
MENTAL HEALTH TO TRANSIT ON A
DAILY BASIS, THE SCOPE, COSTS
AND CONDITIONS OF THESE
CONTRACTS ARE CHALLENGING AND AT
TIMES IMPOSSIBLE TO ACCESS. EVEN
WITH SUCH RECORDS BEING SUBJECT
TO THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC RECORDS
ACT. WITHOUT COMMON SENSE
OVERSIGHT MEASURES PUSHING
PUBLIC SERVICES TO THE PRIVATE
SECTOR HAS PROVEN TO LEAD TO
WASTED TAXPAYER DOLLARS. THE
DEGRADATION, DEGRADATION OF
PUBLIC SECTOR WORKFORCE AND THE
DETERIORATION OF QUALITY PUBLIC
SERVICES. AB 2557 AIMS TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE BY MAKING
THESE CONTRACTS READILY
ACCESSIBLE TO THE PUBLIC. WITH
THIS TRANSPARENCY, WE CAN ENSURE
THAT TAXPAYER DOLLARS ARE BEING
SPENT MORE WISELY AND
EFFICIENTLY AS IS PROVIDED UNDER
THE BILL REQUIRING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO NOTIFY THE
AFFECTED WORKFORCE AND INCLUDE
ESSENTIAL INFORMATION IN THESE
CONTRACTS IS CRUCIAL FOR
ENSURING THAT THE PUBLIC HAS A
CLEAR UNDERSTANDING OF THE
AGREEMENTS BEING MADE ON THEIR
BEHALF. INFORMATION SUCH AS THE
PARTIES INVOLVED, THE SCOPE OF
WORK AND FINANCIAL DETAILS
SHOULD BE READILY AVAILABLE FOR
ANYONE TO REVIEW. THIS LEVEL OF
DETAIL EMPOWERS RESIDENTS AND
AFFECTED WORKERS TO HOLD OUR
PUBLIC LEADERS ACCOUNTABLE AND
TO PARTICIPATE MORE MEANINGFULLY
IN THE DECISION MAKING PROCESS.
AND WITH THAT, WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR, AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE, YVONNE
FERNANDEZ WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION, A PROUD
CO-SPONSOR OF AB 2557, AS STATED
BY THE AUTHOR AND MY COLLEAGUE,
WE APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK WITH COMMITTEE, WITH
COMMITTEE STAFF AND WORKING ON
THE AMENDMENTS FOR THIS BILL, AS
AMENDED, AB 2557 WILL REQUIRE
LOCAL AGENCIES TO POST CONTRACTS
THEY HAVE ENTERED WITH PRIVATE
SERVICE PROVIDERS ON THEIR
WEBSITES BY 2026. CONTRACTS
BETWEEN LOCAL AGENCIES AND
PRIVATE CONTRACTORS WILL CONTAIN
KEY INFORMATION SUCH AS
FINANCIAL EXPENDITURES AND
DELIVERABLES, FOR THE
INFORMATION OF THE PUBLIC, AB
2557 WILL ALSO REQUIRE LOCAL
AGENCIES TO NOTIFY BARGAINING
UNITS OF OUTSOURCING. AB 2557
AIMS AT ADDRESSING THE
WIDESPREAD PRACTICE OF
OUTSOURCING BY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. CONTRACTING OUT HAS
LED TO A DECLINE IN HIGH QUALITY
SERVICES AND THE DEGRADATION OF
THE PUBLIC SECTOR. IN REGARDS TO
THE PUBLIC SECTOR, CONTRACTING
OUT HAS LED TO THE ELIMINATION
OF MIDDLE CLASS CAREER
OPPORTUNITIES, THAT HAVE
AFFECTED BIPOC INDIVIDUALS AND
WOMEN. PREVIOUSLY VIEWED AS THE
BACKBONE OF THE MIDDLE CLASS,
PUBLIC SECTOR, JOBS PROVIDED
COMMUNITY MEMBERS WITH LONG
TERM, SUSTAINABLE EMPLOYMENT.
TODAY, MANY SIMPLY DO NOT HAVE
THESE OPPORTUNITIES DUE TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS CHOOSING TO UTILIZE
A QUICK, CONTRACTED WORKFORCE IN
TERMS OF SERVICE DELIVERY,
CONTRACTORS DO NOT POSSESS THE
SAME QUALIFICATIONS OR TRAINING
AS IN-HOUSE PUBLIC SECTOR
WORKERS, WHICH HAS LED TO
CRUCIAL SERVICES BEING PROVIDED
BY LESS QUALIFIED CONTRACTORS TO
COMMUNITIES IN NEED. THE CURRENT
PROCESS OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
APPROVING AND RE APPROVING
CONTRACT CONTRACTS NEEDS
IMPROVEMENT GIVEN THE FISCAL
ENVIRONMENT WE'RE IN, WE NEED TO
ENSURE EVERY DOLLAR SPENT
EFFECTIVELY. AB 2557 INCREASES
TRANSPARENCY ON CONTRACTS
BETWEEN PRIVATE SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
BY BY REQUIRING CONTRACTS BE
MADE PUBLICLY AVAILABLE, AND BY
FOSTERING PUBLIC EMPLOYEE
RELATIONS. FOR THESE REASONS, WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MOVING
ON TO OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF AB
2557, PLEASE COME FORWARD. AND
SINCE WE'VE HEARD OUR TWO KEY
WITNESSES, WE'RE ASKING EVERYONE
IN SUPPORT TO PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME AND ORGANIZATION AND SAY
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. ANDREW B¢O, ON BEHALF
OF SEIU CALIFORNIA, PROUD
CO-SPONSORS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. HI, JANELLE. JANELLE JOKES
S¼ 721 LA COUNTY NURSE IN
SUPPORT. HELLO. HELLO. HI MY
NAME IS CYNTHIA WHITE AND I WORK
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. AND I'M AN SEIU 721
MEMBER. AND I SUPPORT S AB 2557.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. HELLO. MY
NAME IS ANGEL JONES. I WORK FOR
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH SERVICES.
I'M AN SEIU 2721 MEMBER AND I
SUPPORT THE AB 2557 BILL. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, ROBERT GARCIA
, GOVERNING BOARD MEMBER, SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND CANDIDATE FOR STATE
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT 50. I'M HERE
IN SOLIDARITY WITH SEIU 721, AND
I STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF
AB 2557. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS RAUL
CAMPBELL. I WORK AT SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY CHILDREN AND
FAMILY SERVICES. I AM AN SEIU 71
MEMBER, AND I AM ALSO IN SUPPORT
OF AB 2557. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. HELLO. MY NAME IS BRANDY
WILLIAMS. I'M A CHILDREN'S
SOCIAL WORKER FOR RIVERSIDE
COUNTY. I'M AN SEIU 721 MEMBER,
AND I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU. HI, MY NAME IS
ERIC BUSH. I WORK FOR, CITY OF
RIVERSIDE IN THE SENIOR AND
DISABLED TRANSPORTATION. I'M A
MEMBER OF SEIU 721, AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. HELLO. GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS JOHN CHÁVEZ. I WORK
FOR RIVERSIDE UNIVERSITY HEALTH
SYSTEMS AS A CLINICAL THERAPIST,
AND I'M WITH SEIU 721. AND I'M
HERE TO SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS
PABLO REYES. I'M AN EMPLOYMENT
SERVICES COUNSELOR IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY. I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THE AB 5527. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
MY NAME IS JUAN OMAR, AND I'M A
SOCIAL WORKER IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY. I'M A MEMBER OF SEIU
721, AND I SUPPORT BILL AB 2557.
THANK YOU FOR COMING. HELLO.
GOOD. GOOD MORNING, MY NAME IS
ALAN JORDAN. I WORK AT SAINT
JOHN'S COMMUNITY HEALTH CLINIC.
I AM THE HEALTH EDUCATOR THERE,
AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF BILL AB
2557. THANK YOU. HELLO,
EVERYBODY. MY NAME IS CHIRLA
RUIZ. I WORK FOR A TRANSGENDER
HEALTH PROGRAM OF THE SAINT
JOHNS CLINIC, AND I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT YOU, THE AB 2052 50. I'M
SORRY, 2557. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING. I'M GARY POE.
I'M AN OUTREACH COORDINATOR FOR
14 YEARS AT SAINT JOHN'S
COMMUNITY HEALTH AND I'M AN SEIU
721 MEMBER. AND I SUPPORT AB
2557. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE. MY NAME IS
FIONA HANLON. I'M A REGISTERED
NURSE AT LÀ GENERAL HOSPITAL FOR
25 YEARS. I'M A MEMBER OF SEIU
721 AND I SUPPORT AB 2557. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN. MY NAME IS CINDY
MAGDALENO. I'VE BEEN WITH LA
COUNTY FOR 39 YEARS. I WORKED
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
SERVICES AND I AM STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF AB 2557. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MY NAME IS IRENE LEÓN
CHÁVEZ. I WORK FOR LOS ANGELES
COUNTY FOR 39 YEARS. I SUPPORT
AB 2557. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
HI. GOOD MORNING EVERYONE. MY
NAME IS CYNTHIA MITCHELL. I WORK
FOR LOS ANGELES COUNTY. I'VE
BEEN EMPLOYED THERE FOR 24
YEARS. I WORK AT LOS ANGELES
GENERAL IN THE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT. I AM A SEIU 721
MEMBER AND I SUPPORT AB 2557.
YOU GUYS HAVE A GOOD DAY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. HELLO. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS PATRICK
DELCONTE. I WORK FOR LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH. I'M
A MENTAL HEALTH TRANSFORMATION
ADVOCATE. I'M ALSO AN SEO LOCAL
721 MEMBER, AND I'M IN SUPPORT
OF AB 2557. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SIR. GOOD MORNING. MY
NAME IS AMISHA BURRIS AND I WORK
AT LOS ANGELES COUNTY DEPARTMENT
OF CHILDREN AND FAMILY SERVICES,
AND I'M A MEMBER OF SEIU 721,
AND I SUPPORT AB 2557. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS ASHLEY
GUZMAN. I WORK FOR SAINT JOHNS
COMMUNITY HEALTH. I AM AN SEIU
721 MEMBER, AND I ALSO SUPPORT
AB 2557. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS VANESSA
WILLIAMS. I WORK FOR THE COUNTY
OF LOS ANGELES AT LOS ANGELES
GENERAL MEDICAL CENTER, IN THE
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT FOR PATIENT
ACCESS CENTER AND I AM A PROUD
MEMBER OF THE LOCAL 721 SEIU
MEMBER. AND I SUPPORT AB 2557.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME
IS AISHA. I WORK FOR THE COUNTY
OF LOS ANGELES AS A COUNTY
SOCIAL WORKER. I'M A PROUD
MEMBER OF SEIU 721 AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF AB 2557. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. HELLO, MY NAME IS
EVANGELINA MADRID AND I WORK AT
LOS ANGELES COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
MENTAL HEALTH. I'M A PROUD
MEMBER OF S¼. HIÂU 721 AND I AM
IN SUPPORT OF AB 2557. THANK
YOU. HELLO. GOOD MORNING TO ALL.
MY NAME IS MOBECK UMMUL. I'M A
MENTAL HEALTH COUNSELOR AND I
WORK FOR L.A. COUNTY DEPARTMENT
OF MENTAL HEALTH AND I'M HERE
BECAUSE I AM A MEMBER AND PROUD
MEMBER OF LOCAL 721 SEIU. AND I
SUPPORT AB 257. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. HI. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME
IS RUTH CASTILLO. I AM A
REGISTERED NURSE, DEPARTMENT OF
MENTAL HEALTH. I ALSO SUPPORT AB
2557 AND I AM A PROUD MEMBER OF
SEIU 721. THANK YOU. TOO MANY
NUMBERS, YEAH. HI. MY NAME IS
MEGAN UMMUL. I WORK AT HARBOR
UCLA. I'M A PROUD MEMBER OF THE
SEIU, 721, AND I AM IN SUPPORT
OF THE AB 2557. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. HI. MY NAME IS JASMINE
RUBIO. I'M REPRESENTING, A
MEMBER OF 721, AND I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT THE AB 227. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME
IS IVONA WISEMAN. I WORK FOR
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH SERVICES.
I'M A PROUD MEMBER OF SEIU 721.
AND I'M HERE TO IN SUPPORT OF AB
2557. THANK YOU. HI. MY NAME IS
IRENE RODRIGUEZ. I WORK FOR L.A.
COUNTY. I AM A721. YEAH 721
MEMBER AB AND I SUPPORT AS WELL.
THANK YOU. HI. MY NAME IS
LEILANI AND I AM A MEMBER OF
SEIU 721. I'M A UNION STEWARD AT
WEST VALLEY. DPS AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF AB 2557. THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS VERONICA JOHNSON. I'M
WITH THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES
AND I'M WITH LOCAL 721, AND I
SUPPORT AB 20 2557. THANK YOU.
HELLO EVERYONE. MY NAME IS
SANDRA BUENROSTRO AND I'M A
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE FOR THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH AND I'M IN SUPPORT
OF SB 2557 AND MY SEIU 721 UNION
MEMBER. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS JASON
CALIXTO. I WORK FOR THE COUNTY
OF LOS ANGELES AT L.A. GENERAL
MEDICAL CENTER FOR THE
CUSTODIANS. WE ARE ALL IN
SUPPORT OF AB 2557. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. MY NAME IS ROSE MANU.
I WORK FOR DPS LA COUNTY. I'M A
SEIU MEMBER AND I'M HERE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. HELLO, MY
NAME IS JESSICA. I'M WITH
RIVERSIDE COUNTY. I'M AN SEIU
MEMBER. 721 IN SUPPORT OF AB
2557. THANK YOU. GO AHEAD. HI.
MY NAME IS KIM HOLLAND. I'M A
HERE FROM LA COUNTY. I'M A
MEMBER OF SEVEN TWO SEIU 721 IN
FAVOR OF AB 2557. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. HELLO. GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE. MY NAME IS JOHNNY
MORALES AND I WORK AT CLINICA
ROMERO. I AM A SU, 721 MEMBER
AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF AB 2557.
THANK YOU. SENATE-DISTRICT
MONNING. GOOD MORNING, I'M TISHA
RUSH. I REPRESENT LOS ANGELES
COUNTY, I AM AN SEIU 721 MEMBER
IN SUPPORT OF AB 2557. THANK YOU
. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS
BRANDY COMPTON. I WORK AT
GATEWAYS HOSPITAL. I'M A SEVEN
Â. I USE SEIU 2721 MEMBER IN
SUPPORT OF AB 2557. THANK YOU.
MENTAL HEALTH CLINIC. OUR
FACILITY. HELLO. MY NAME IS
KRISTA RAMIREZ. I WORK AT THE
WATTS HEALTH CENTER. I'M A SEIU
721 MEMBER IN SUPPORT OF THE AB
2557. THANK YOU. MORNING. MY
NAME IS NANCY RODRIGUEZ. I WORK
AT WATTS HEALTH CENTER. I AM
SEIU 721 MEMBER SUPPORTING AB
2557. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS TERRY EVANS. I'M A
REGISTERED DENTAL ASSISTANT AT
THE WATTS HEALTH CENTER. I'M IN
FAVOR OF THE SB 2557. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS LINDA
BUTLER. I AM AN EMPLOYEE AT DPS.
I'M AN SEIU 721 MEMBER, AND I'M
IN SUPPORT OF AB 2557. THANK YOU
. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS
DEIDRE BETTY, I WORK AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH SERVICES. I
AM A LOCAL SEIU 721 MEMBER, AND
I'M IN SUPPORT OF AB 2557. THANK
YOU. AND WHO IS THIS YOUNG LADY?
JULIE. HI, JULIE. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? GREAT, SEEING NONE,
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION, COULD YOU
COULD YOU LET HIM? WE'LL HAVE
YOU ONE AT A TIME. GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING. AND THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. YES I'M BRUCE
GIBSON, SAN LUIS. CAN'T HEAR
YOU. IS THAT. IS IT IS IT ON? I
AM OKAY, SURE. HOW'S THAT? THERE
YOU GO. CLOSER. THERE WE GO. AND
BEING SO CLOSE, I NEED MY
GLASSES, I'M BRUCE GIBSON, SAN
LUIS OBISPO COUNTY SUPERVISOR
AND PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES.
THE VOICE OF ALL 58 COUNTIES,
ALSO KNOWN AS CSAC. CSAC OPPOSES
AB 2557, QUITE SIMPLY BECAUSE IT
WILL HARM OUR ABILITY TO CARE
FOR THE 39 MILLION CALIFORNIANS,
YOUR CHAMBER AND OUR BOARD'S
MUTUAL Kò SERVE. AS YOU KNOW,
COUNTIES ARE SERVICE PROVIDERS,
ESPECIALLY FOR THE MOST
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS AND WE
HAVE LONG DEPENDED ON BOTH OUR
OUTSTANDING COUNTY STAFF AND OUR
CONTRACTING PARTNERS IN ORDER TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF OUR RESIDENTS,
AB 2557 REPORTING AND NOTICING
REQUIREMENTS ARE BURDENSOME,
DUPLICATIVE, AND IMPRACTICAL.
COUNTIES WILL INCUR SIGNIFICANT
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS IN MEETING
THEM, AND WE ARE ALSO ALL ALSO
ALREADY PERCEIVED AS SLOW. AND
AB 2557 WILL SLOW US DOWN
FURTHER. IN SAN LUIS OBISPO
COUNTY, OUR CONTRACTING PARTNERS
ARE VARIOUS AND BUT I'M
ESPECIALLY PROUD OF OUR
NONPROFIT SECTOR PARTNERS AND
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE WITH THE
PROPONENT WHO TESTIFIED. OUR
PARTNERS PROVIDE US OUTSTANDING
SERVICE AND SIGNIFICANT
EXPERTISE IN AREAS WHICH OUR
COUNTY CAN'T MATCH IN HOMELESS
SERVICES. THEY ADDRESS HOUSING,
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE TREATMENTS. IN OUR JAIL,
THEY PROVIDE HEALTH CARE AFTER
HORRIFIC DEATH HAS GREATLY
IMPROVED THAT SERVICE. IN AN
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT FOR ALL.
THEY PROVIDE GREAT EXPERTISE. AB
2557 WILL DISCOURAGE
PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND PRIVATE ENTITIES
AND ON BEHALF OF CSAC, I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT IF IT IS
PERCEIVED THAT COUNTY
CONTRACTING HAS IMPERFECTIONS OR
COULD BE IMPROVED, WE ARE MORE
THAN HAPPY TO SIT DOWN AND HAVE
A CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW THAT
MIGHT HAPPEN. BUT AB 2557
REPRESENTS A SWEEPING CHANGE TO
THE FUNDAMENTAL WORK OF COUNTY
GOVERNMENT. CREATES ADDITIONAL
LAYERS OF ADMINISTRATIVE
BUREAUCRACY, AND IT WON'T
IMPROVE THE DELIVERY OF COUNTY
SERVICES. OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES,
YES, FACE A TREMENDOUS
CHALLENGES. THEY DESERVE A
CONTRACTING SYSTEM THAT WORKS
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS. WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
OPPOSITION ON THIS BILL. THANK
YOU SIR. NEXT IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR, AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS JOSE VARGAS WITH UNITED
WAYS OF CALIFORNIA HERE IN
RESPECTFUL, ONGOING OPPOSITION
TO AB 2557, WE REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR LEADERSHIP, MADAM CHAIR,
AND YOUR STAFF'S EFFORTS TO
ENGAGE WITH US. THE AUTHOR AND
THE SPONSORS, TO SUBSTANTIVELY
ADDRESS SOME OF THE MANY
CONCERNS THAT WE'VE BEEN RAISING
FOR MONTHS BECAUSE THE LAST
AMENDMENTS WERE SHARED WITH US
YESTERDAY EVENING, WE'RE STILL
REVIEWING THOSE UNITED WAYS OF
CALIFORNIA'S PART OF A NONPROFIT
CONTRACTING COALITION THAT HAS
BEEN WORKING TO STRENGTHEN AND
IMPROVE THE PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN
GOVERNMENT AND NONPROFITS AS
CONVEYED IN A LETTER SENT BY
LEADERS OF MORE THAN 200
NONPROFITS ACROSS CALIFORNIA. WE
URGE YOUR NO VOTE TO AVOID
SIGNIFICANT NEGATIVE IMPACTS
THAT WOULD RESULT FROM THE
BILL'S ENACTMENT, INCLUDING THE
POTENTIAL DISRUPTION OF SERVICE
DELIVERY FOR COUNTLESS
CALIFORNIANS, UNITED WAY'S
PARTNER WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ON A WIDE VARIETY OF CRITICAL
ISSUES, INCLUDING PROVIDING FREE
TAX PREPARATION AND ASSISTANCE,
AND OPERATING TWO AND ONE
INFORMATION AND REFERRAL
SERVICES FOR MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS. GOVERNMENTS TURN
TO NONPROFITS TO EXTEND THEIR
REACH AND HELP DELIVER CRITICAL
SERVICES, INCLUDING HEALTH CARE,
FOOD AID, SHELTER, ANIMAL
WELFARE, JUVENILE JUSTICE,
IMMIGRATION SUPPORT, LEGAL AID,
AND SO MUCH MORE. WE HAVE A LONG
AND PROVEN TRACK RECORD OF
PROVIDING QUALITY, COST
EFFECTIVE, LINGUISTICALLY AND
CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE SERVICES
THAT ARE TRUSTED BY AND DEEPLY
CONNECTED TO COMMUNITIES OF ALL
TYPES. CALIFORNIANS TRUST
NONPROFITS TO DELIVER SERVICES
BY MARGINS AS MUCH AS 40
PERCENTAGE POINTS HIGHER THAN
EITHER THE PRIVATE SECTOR OR
GOVERNMENT. A ROBUST NONPROFIT
SECTOR COMPLEMENTS A STRONG
PUBLIC SECTOR, AND BOTH BENEFIT
FROM MORE COLLABORATION, LIKE
THE EFFORT BY CIVIC LEADERS,
NONPROFIT PROVIDERS AND PUBLIC
EMPLOYEE UNION LEADERS IN LOS
ANGELES WHO TOGETHER DEVELOPED A
FRAMEWORK THAT'S PART OF A
MEASURE HEADED FOR THE NOVEMBER
BALLOT THAT WOULD RAISE MORE
THAN $1 BILLION ANNUALLY
SUPPORTING HOMELESS SERVICES AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CONSTRUCTION.
IN SHORT, WE ALL WORK TOGETHER
FOR THE BETTERMENT OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. WE CALL FOR A NO
VOTE TODAY BECAUSE WE WOULD FAR
PREFER TO FIND A PATH FORWARD
THAT ENSURES ROBUST PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT AND PROVES THE
ABILITY OF NONPROFITS TO SERVE
AS PARTNERS FOR OR TO
GOVERNMENT, AND CONTINUES TO
ENSURE QUALITY SERVICES FOR
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE COUNTING ON
BOTH THE PUBLIC AND NONPROFIT
SECTORS TO WORK TOGETHER ON
THEIR BEHALF. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, AND IF OTHERS WHO ARE IN
OPPOSITION, IF YOU WOULD JUST
COME UP TO THE MIC AND GIVE US
YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION.
THÀNH, THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. I'M ASHLEY LUGO ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS IN OPPOSITION TO
AB 2557. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. LARA, ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTY RECORDERS ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA, RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
, DYLAN FINLEY, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PARK AND RECREATION
SOCIETY, THE TAHOE, WATER FOR
FIRE SUPPRESSION PARTNERSHIP AND
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. I'M RASHEED WITH THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR
DARBY KERNAN, ON BEHALF OF THE
EMS ADMINISTRATORS ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA, AND ON BEHALF OF
MEALS ON WHEELS, CALIFORNIA AND
THEN WE DIDN'T GET OUR LETTER IN
ON TIME, BUT AMITY FOUNDATION IS
ALSO IN OPPOSITION. AND AS YOU,
MADAM CHAIR, HAVE BEEN THERE AND
SEEN THIS AS WE ARE IMPLEMENTING
CAL AIM, ALL OF THESE NONPROFITS
ARE CONTRACTING WITH COUNTIES IN
THE STATE, AND THIS WILL THROW A
COMPLETE INTERRUPTION THÀNH INTO
PEOPLE GETTING REENTRY SERVICES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS.
JASON GONSALVES, ON BEHALF OF
THE CITIES OF FAIRFIELD,
LAKEWOOD, ALAMEDA AND THOUSAND
OAKS IN OPPOSITION, I'D PUT THIS
IN THE GREAT AUTHOR BAD BILL
CATEGORY. THANK YOU. CAITLYN
DEAN, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES, IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION, ALSO ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTY VETERANS SERVICES
OFFICERS, THE COUNTY OF
SACRAMENTO AND THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU, ALYSSA SALEHI, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF RECREATION AND
PARK DISTRICTS, AND ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE CITIES OF
BAKERSFIELD CITY OF FOSTER CITY,
CITY OF MERCED, CITY OF CORONA,
AND TOWN OF HILLSBORO. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. FAITH BURGESS,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITIES IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
JASON EICHER, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION. ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU, JULIE MALINOWSKI.
PAUL, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION AND THE FIRE
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA, IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU, SARAH DUQUETTE, ON BEHALF
OF THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS HALF
OF THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS HERE IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
JOHNNY PINA. WITH THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, ANDREW MENDOZA, ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
OFFICIALS IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. GOOD, MORNING, MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. GOOD MORNING, THANK
GOD IT'S, CHRIS REIF ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION. OPPOSITION ALSO
HAVE PERMISSION TO SAY ON BEHALF
OF THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS, TRADERS
ALSO IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR AARON AVERY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED
ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SANITATION
AGENCIES, THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES, AND
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
NICOLE WATERMAN, ON BEHALF OF
SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY, IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
HEARST HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA, THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC HOSPITALS
AND HEALTH SYSTEMS, THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION,
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH EXECUTIVES, AND THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS ALL RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. DYLAN ELLIOTT, ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTIES OF BUTTE,
FRESNO, KERN, MADERA, MERCED,
PLACER, SAN JOAQUIN, STANISLAUS,
AND THE PUBLIC RISK SOLUTIONS
AND MANAGEMENT ORGANIZATION, ALL
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO THE
VERSION IN PRINT. LOOKING
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO REVIEW.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, JEFF
NEEL REPRESENTING THE COUNTY OF
CONTRA COSTA. ALSO IN OPPOSITION
. GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR.
JENNIFER FEARING, ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
NONPROFITS AND ALSO SAN DIEGO
HUMANE SOCIETY, I WANT TO ECHO
THE GRATITUDE EXPRESSED BY MY
COLLEAGUE WITH UNITED WAYS OF
CALIFORNIA FOR THE WORK THAT YOU
AND YOUR STAFF HAVE DONE TO HELP
TRY TO MOVE THIS ISSUE ALONG.
WE'RE STILL REVIEWING THE
AMENDMENTS, BUT REMAIN IN AN
OPPOSED POSITION. RESPECTFULLY,
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. TRENT
MURPHY, REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ALCOHOL AND DRUG PROGRAM
EXECUTIVES, ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WELL,
THERE'S NOBODY ELSE WHO CAN
SPEAK EXCEPT ME. YOU'RE STUCK
WITH ME, I, I REALLY APPRECIATE
WORKING OUR STAFF, WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR AND WITH YOUR STAFF
ON THIS. IT'S BEEN. IT'S BEEN
DIFFICULT BECAUSE EVERYBODY'S
RIGHT, WE NEED A PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND OUR ENTITIES, LOCAL
ENTITIES, TO BE ABLE TO COUNT ON
PARTNERSHIPS WITH, BOTH PRIVATE
SECTOR, WHICH A LOT OF PRIVATE
SECTOR ARE IMPACTED IN THIS WAY.
AND WITH OUR NONPROFIT SECTOR, I
DON'T THINK WE CAN FULFILL ALL
OF THE NEEDS THAT WE HAVE IN
LOCAL GOVERNMENT WITHOUT, AT ONE
POINT OR ANOTHER, HAVING
PARTNERSHIPS. SO WE ALL AGREE. I
THINK WE ALL AGREE WITH THAT.
THE ISSUE THAT CAME TO ME,
THROUGH THIS BILL IS THAT THERE
IS A LACK OF INFORMATION
AVAILABLE IN A MORE CENTRALIZED
WAY, AND A CLEAR WAY, AND
NOTIFICATION WHEN CONTRACTING
DOES GO OUT TO A PRIVATE SECTOR
OR A NONPROFIT, SO THAT, TO ME
MAKES SENSE BECAUSE WE SHOULD
KNOW WHAT WE SHOULD HAVE THE
INFORMATION AVAILABLE TO US WHEN
THIS IS BEING DONE. AND WE
SHOULD KNOW WHAT THE SERVICES
ARE THAT ARE BEING PROVIDED AND
KNOW WHAT SALARIES ARE BEING
PAID. AND JUST LIKE WE DO IN
HOUSE, EVERYBODY IN HOUSE, IN
LOCAL GOVERNMENT, WE KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT THEY MAKE, WHAT
THEIR WHAT SERVICES ARE
PROVIDING. WE HAVE EXPECTATIONS
OF ALL OF OUR IN HOUSE,
EMPLOYEES OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
AND, WE CAN FOLLOW WHAT THEY'RE
DOING WHEN THEY'RE NOT DOING
SOMETHING. WE CAN FOLLOW THAT AS
WELL. AND IT SEEMS TO ME ANYBODY
WHO IS, RECEIVING A CONTRACT
BASED ON, YOU KNOW, BASED THAT'S
COMING FROM OUR TAX DOLLARS, WE
SHOULDN'T HAVE A DIFFERENT
STANDARD OR A DIFFERENT
EXPECTATION, FOR ME, THOSE WERE
THE, PRIMARY ISSUES. THIS IS NOT
ANTI NONPROFIT. THIS IS NOT ANTI
PRIVATE SECTOR. WHO ARE ALSO
RECEIVE MANY, MANY CONTRACTS
FROM OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT. THERE
WAS SOME REFERENCE BUT I THINK
ONE OF THE KEY KEY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION THAT TALKED ABOUT
THIS WOULD CAUSE DISRUPTION. I'M
NOT EXACTLY SURE WHAT THAT MEANS
, THE EFFORT THAT WE PUT INTO
MAKING SURE THAT THERE WAS TIME
ALLOWED, FOR THE INFORMATION,
THE NOTIFICATION. THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
TOMORROW, EVEN THOUGH SOME
PEOPLE MIGHT HAVE WANTED THAT,
IT'S THAT'S NOT WHAT WE'RE WHAT
WE'RE DOING HERE. I THINK, WELL,
THOSE ARE MY PRIMARY ISSUES THAT
MOVED US, AND I APPRECIATE THAT
YOU'VE ACCEPTED, THE, AMENDMENTS
THAT WE'VE OFFERED. I THINK
THERE'S ONE MORE, 120 DAYS.
YEAH, I WAS TOLD BY ONE OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ON THE
120 DAYS, IF YOU COULD. YES SAY
WHAT? THAT WILL SAY WHAT THAT
IS. WE WILL REMOVE THE CLAUSE
AROUND THE REPORTING WITHIN THE
120 DAYS AND JUST MAKE IT WITHIN
A REASONABLE TIME. OKAY OKAY.
SO, I DON'T KNOW IF THAT HELPS
OR, TO CLARIFY, FOR ANY OF THE
OPPOSITION HÌNH, WITNESSES, BUT
THAT'S THE LATEST AMENDMENT THAT
WAS MADE AND ACCEPTED. I THINK
THAT'S IT. THAT'S IT FOR ME. IF
YOU WANT TO MAKE ANY FINAL
REMARKS, JUST WANT TO THANK YOU
AGAIN AND YOUR TEAM FOR WORKING
WITH US AND MAKING SURE THAT WE
DO GET TO THAT GOAL OF
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
AS WAS MENTIONED EARLIER, THIS
WAS NOT A BILL TO PUNISH OUR
NONPROFITS, BUT TO WORK
TOGETHER. IT'S HARD TO WORK
TOGETHER WHEN WE DON'T SEE THE
DATA AND ARE ABLE TO ACCESS THE
RESULTS IN WHICH WE'RE LOOKING
FOR IN A VERY CLEAR AND DIRECT
MANNER. AND, YOU KNOW, ONCE
AGAIN, SOMEONE SAID THIS WAS A
GOOD AUTHOR, BAD BILL, AND, YOU
KNOW, I'LL I'LL GO BACK TO MY
OPENING STATEMENT, WHICH IS, YOU
KNOW, I'M REALLY SHOCKED. FROM
THE BEGINNING, THIS HAS JUST
BEEN A TRANSPARENCY BILL ABOUT
BEING ACCOUNTABLE TO OUR
TAXPAYERS. I AM ASKED EVERY DAY
WHAT OUR TAXPAYER DOLLARS ARE
GOING TO. AND THEREFORE, I WAS
ASKING OUR PARTNERS THE SAME
QUESTION IN A WAY THAT COULD BE
CLEAR AND DIRECT AND IN THAT,
YOU KNOW, FOUND SOME UPSETTING
INFORMATION, WHEN YOU HAVE SOME
OF OUR NONPROFIT EXECUTIVES
MAKING MORE THAN THE GOVERNOR,
IT'S, YOU KNOW, I QUESTION, WHY
THIS HAS BEEN SUCH A HARD THING
TO, TO DISCUSS AND MOVE THROUGH,
BUT WITH THAT, I WILL
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE
WHEN THE WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND WE WILL
HAVE THE VOTE LATER WHEN WE GET
OUR QUORUM. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE. THANK YOU FOR
EVERYONE WHO CAME FROM,
ESPECIALLY FROM OUT OF TOWN.
YES GOOD MORNING. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. GOOD MORNING CHAIRWOMAN.
AND YOU WILL BE TAKING UP AB
2661. THAT'S CORRECT. THANK YOU.
WELCOME. AND YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. CHAIR,
AB 2661 HAS PROPOSED TO BE
AMENDED. WILL BE WILL HELP
ACHIEVE CALIFORNIA'S RENEWABLE
RENEWABLE GOALS BY LEVERAGING
THE EXISTING CAPABILITIES OF
WESTLANDS WATER DISTRICT TO
DELIVER NEW SOLAR GENERATION AND
TRANSMISSION LINES, TO COMBAT
THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE,
CALIFORNIA HAS SET AMBITIOUS
GOALS TO INCREASE THE USE OF
CLEAN ENERGY, AIMING TO ACHIEVE
60% ELIGIBLE RENEWABLE ENERGY BY
2030 AND 100% ZERO CARBON ENERGY
BY 2045, TO MEET THESE GOALS,
NEW RENEWABLE GENERATION
FACILITIES AND THOUSANDS OF
MILES OF NEW TRANSMISSION LINES
ARE NEEDED. THE CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT SYSTEM OPERATOR HAS
ALREADY IDENTIFIED AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DEVELOP 30,000MW
OF SOLAR IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY. CALLISTO'S
IDENTIFICATION OF THESE
POTENTIAL RESOURCES IS
ESPECIALLY TIMELY GIVEN THE
CHANGES OCCURRING IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY DUE TO THE SUSTAINABLE
GROUNDWATER, GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT ACT, KNOWN AS SIGMA,
AS GROUNDWATER BASINS ADOPT
SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT PLANS, MANY REGIONS
OF THE STATE ARE EXPECTED TO
EXPERIENCE AS MUCH AS 20%
DECLINE IN AVAILABLE AVAILABLE
WATER SUPPLY BY 2030. THIS IS
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AS WE'RE SEEING
MORE AND MORE LANDS BEING
FALLOWED AS A RESULT OF SIGMA
DUE TO THIS MASSIVE CHANGE,
SPECIFICALLY, IT'S ESTIMATED
THAT BETWEEN 500,000 AND 900,000
ACRES OF FARMLAND MAY NEED TO BE
FALLOWED JUST IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY ALONE. THIS FALLOWED FARM
CAN BE THE KEY TO EXPANDING OUR
SOLAR GENERATION IN, WESTLANDS
WATER DISTRICT. WHO IS IN THE
BEST POSITION TO IDENTIFY
SUSTAINABLE, SUITABLE FALLOWED
FARMLAND IN THEIR SERVICE
TERRITORY FOR CONVERSION TO
SOLAR GENERATION CAN HELP
CONTRIBUTE TO THE STATE'S
RENEWABLE ENERGY PORTFOLIO WHILE
MAKING UP FOR THE LOST WATER
SUPPLY REVENUE REVENUES NEEDED
TO CONTINUE SERVING THE
REMAINING WATER CUSTOMERS.
UNFORTUNATELY, THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH TRANSMISSION CURRENTLY
PLANNED FOR THE CENTRAL VALLEY
TO CAPITALIZE ON THIS
OPPORTUNITY. AB 2661 WILL GIVE
WESTLANDS WATER DISTRICT THE
AUTHORITY TO BUILD, OWN AND
OPERATE TRANSMISSION LINES TO
CONNECT THIS NEW GENERATION TO
THE GRID. THIS WILL HELP US
ACHIEVE OUR CLIMATE GOALS WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY PROVIDE AN
INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN
PLACES LIKE WEST FRESNO COUNTY,
WHERE THE NEED FOR SKILLED AND
WELL-PAYING JOBS ARE CRITICAL.
THE PROJECTS THAT COULD BE
UNDERTAKEN THROUGH THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL WILL
HELP THESE WORKERS UPSKILL AND
ENTER INTO THE TRADES WHICH WILL
UPLIFT THESE COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE OFTEN LEFT OUT OF THE
CONVERSATION WHEN IT COMES TO
INVESTMENTS, WITH ME HERE TODAY
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT, WE HAVE
ELIZABETH JOHNSON ON BEHALF OF
WESTLANDS WATER DISTRICT AND
MARK JOSEPH ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION OF UTILITY
WORKERS. GOOD MORNING. WELCOME.
HI. GOOD MORNING. THANK YOU.
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY OR
REMIND YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
YES, I'LL BE BRIEF, FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE A
TESTIMONY TODAY. I'M ELIZABETH
JOHNSON, DEPUTY GENERAL MANAGER
FOR WESTLANDS WATER DISTRICT.
WESTLANDS IS A CALIFORNIA WATER
DISTRICT SERVING 614,000 ACRES
IN WESTERN FRESNO AND KINGS
COUNTY. AB 2661 WOULD PROVIDE
AUTHORITIES TO WESTLANDS THAT
ARE CRUCIAL FOR ALLOWING OUR
DISTRICT TO EFFECTIVELY PLAN AND
PROVIDE STRATEGIC OVERSIGHT OF
LAND BEING TRANSITIONED OUT OF
AGRICULTURAL USE TO SOLAR WITHIN
OUR DISTRICT. THE NEED TO
TRANSITION THIS LAND HAS BEEN
DRIVEN BY WATER SUPPLY,
RELIABILITY PROBLEMS IN THE
DELTA OVER THE LAST DECADE, LAND
FALLOWING HAS VARIED BETWEEN 120
TO 220,000 ACRES. AND NOW, WITH
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT ACT, OUR FARMERS WILL
HAVE LESS WATER AVAILABLE. SOLAR
DEVELOPMENT HAS EMERGED AS A
LAND REPURPOSING APPROACH THAT
PROVIDES A PRODUCTIVE USE OF THE
LAND, PROVIDING JOBS AND
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES, WHILE AT THE SAME
TIME HELPING MEET THE STATE'S
RENEWABLE ENERGY GOALS. AS WE
HAVE BEGUN A CEQA PROGRAMMATIC
ENVIRONMENTAL PROCESS FOR THE
LONG TERM. BUT TEMPORARY
CONVERSION OF 130,000 ACRES OF
SOLAR GENERATION WITH THE HOPE
THAT AT THE END OF THE PROJECT'S
USEFUL LIFE, APPROXIMATELY 30
YEARS AS APPROPRIATE, THE LAND
CAN BE RETURNED TO IRRIGATED
AGRICULTURE. OUR OVERSIGHT
PROVIDED THROUGH THIS BILL WOULD
ALLOW WESTLANDS TO FAVOR
TRANSITION OF LANDS THAT ARE
MARGINAL DRAINAGE IMPAIRED, OR
WHICH ARE IDEAL FOR DUAL USES
SUCH AS FLOOD WATER RECHARGE,
AGRIVOLTAICS AND THE LIKE. IT
WILL ALSO ALLOW US TO MANAGE THE
LANDS CONSISTENT WITH OUR
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY PLAN,
THE SURROUNDING USES AND
COMMUNITY NEEDS, AND TO BETTER
PRESERVE THE AGRICULTURAL
HERITAGE OF THE DISTRICT AS IT
MAKES THE SIGNIFICANT TRANSITION
FOR THE NEXT 30 YEARS. WE
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
SORIA'S LEADERSHIP ON THIS BILL
AND ASK FOR THIS COMMITTEE'S
APPROVAL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. GOOD MORNING,
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS. MY NAME
IS MARK JOSEPH. I'M TESTIFYING
ON BEHALF OF THE COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA UTILITY EMPLOYEES, AB
2661 IS AN ELEGANT SOLUTION TO
SEVERAL WELL-KNOWN PROBLEMS. WE
NEED LOTS MORE ELECTRIC
TRANSMISSION TO DELIVER CLEAN
ENERGY. WE HAVE TO CONTROL
ELECTRIC RATES. WE NEED TO FIX
THE MAJOR TRANSMISSION
CONSTRAINT THAT IS FORCING LOTS
OF SOLAR GENERATION IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA TO BE CURTAILED
BECAUSE IT CAN'T REACH NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA, WHICH IS WASTING
LOTS OF MONEY. AND WE NEED TO
CREATE INCOME FOR PEOPLE WHOSE
FARMLAND NO LONGER HAS RELIABLE
WATER SUPPLY. OR IS DRAINAGE
IMPAIRED. AND FOR THE PEOPLE
WORKING AND LIVING IN THESE
COMMUNITIES. AND WE NEED TO DO
ALL OF THESE THINGS QUICKLY.
THIS BILL ADDRESSES ALL OF THESE
PROBLEMS BY GIVING THE WESTLANDS
WATER DISTRICT THE AUTHORITY TO
BUILD AND OWN TRANSMISSION LINES
IN THE DISTRICT, ALONG WITH
SOLAR AND HYDROPOWER FOR SALE
INTO THE WHOLESALE ELECTRIC
MARKET. AS YOUR ANALYSIS
CORRECTLY IDENTIFIES, THERE ARE
LOTS OF OTHER TYPES OF DISTRICTS
THAT HAVE SIMILAR AUTHORITY.
THIS BILL WOULD PLUG A GAP IN
THE CODE SO THAT THE WESTLANDS
WATER DISTRICT CAN PLUG A GAP IN
OUR TRANSMISSION SYSTEM. OF
COURSE, THIS WOULD CREATE TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF GOOD JOBS
BUILDING, TRANSMISSION AND
BUILDING SOLAR GENERATION. I
WANT TO STRESS THAT THE BILL
DOES NOT HARDWIRE ANY PARTICULAR
OUTCOME. NOTHING WOULD HAPPEN
UNLESS THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION FINDS THAT
THIS WOULD BE A GOOD DEAL FOR
RATEPAYERS, AND THEN IF AND ONLY
IF IT'S COST EFFECTIVE FOR
RATEPAYERS, THEN THE COMMISSION
WOULD SEND THE RECOMMENDATION TO
THE CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT
SYSTEM OPERATOR THEN IF AND ONLY
IF THE CAISO ALSO SELECTS THE
PROJECT IN ITS ANNUAL
TRANSMISSION PLAN, THE PLAN
COULD PROCEED. AND I WOULD ALSO
NOTE THAT THE WESTLANDS WATER
DISTRICT WOULD NOT REPLACE PGE
AS THE LOCAL ELECTRIC UTILITY.
THE BILL PROHIBITS THE DISTRICT
FROM SELLING ELECTRICITY AT
RETAIL. IT WOULD JUST SUPPLY THE
GENERATION AND TRANSMISSION INTO
THE WHOLESALE MARKET. THANK YOU.
AND WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL. THANK YOU, WE HAVE
ANY MORE? WELL, YEAH. WE NEED TO
OPEN UP TO MORE WITNESSES OR
SUPPORTERS OF AB 23-14. MADAM
CHAIR, MEMBERS, SCOTT, WHICH ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE ASSOCIATION
OF ELECTRICAL WORKERS, A
CO-SPONSOR OF THE BILL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. HELLO. ANTHONY
TANNEHILL, CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR
HUNTER STERN WITH IBEW 1245 AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. DANIEL KIM WITH GOLDEN
STATE CLEAN ENERGY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. THANK YOU. MICHAEL
BOCCADORO, ON BEHALF OF THE AG
ENERGY CONSUMERS ASSOCIATION, IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. DON
WILCOX WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CONFERENCE OF CARPENTERS IN
STRONG SUPPORT, CODY BOYLES ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA CITRUS
MUTUAL IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? SEEING
NONE. ANYONE IN OPPOSITION? NO.
SEEING NONE, MEMBERS, ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS WHEN WE'RE
AT THE QUORUM WILL MOVE THE
BILL, DO YOU HAVE ANY CLOSING
REMARKS, JUST, MADAM CHAIRWOMAN,
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT AB 2661. AND AS SOMEONE
THAT REPRESENTS THE CENTRAL
VALLEY, I, I KNOW THAT THIS, CAN
BE A GAME CHANGER FOR OUR
COMMUNITY, ONE WE CAN HELP MEET
THE CLIMATE GOALS OF THE STATE.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, UPLIFT THE
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN LEFT
BEHIND FOR GENERATIONS. SO THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. AND I WILL BE
SUPPORTING IT. THANK YOU. OKAY,
MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GRAYSON, PLEASE. THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE, YOU WILL BE
PRESENTING AB 3012. OKAY. YOU
CAN PROCEED. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS FIRST. I AM
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE'S
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS, AND I THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR DILIGENT
WORK ON THIS BILL. AB 3012 WILL
HELP PROVIDE GREATER CLARITY ON
DEVELOPMENT FEES THAT MUST BE
PAID DURING THE DEVELOPMENT
PROCESS AND HELP STRENGTHEN
EXISTING REQUIREMENTS FOR IMPACT
FEE TRANSPARENCY IN ORDER TO
PROMOTE TRANSPARENCY AROUND
IMPACT FEES, I AUTHORED AB 1483
BACK IN 2019, WHICH REQUIRED
JURISDICTIONS TO MAKE
INFORMATION ON IMPACT FEES MORE
ACCESSIBLE. THIS INCLUDED THE
ONLINE POSTING OF INFORMATION
SUCH AS IMPACT FEE SCHEDULES,
IMPACT FEE, NEXUS STUDIES AND
OTHER INFORMATION THAT COULD
INFORM A DEVELOPER OF THAT
JURISDICTIONS IMPACT FEES. WHILE
AB 1483 AND OTHER HOUSING
POLICIES HAVE MADE SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS ON IMPACT FEE
TRANSPARENCY, RECENT REPORTS
FROM SPUR FOUND THAT MANY
JURISDICTIONS MAY NOT BE IN FULL
COMPLIANCE WITH THE BILL, AND
THAT INFORMATION ON DEVELOPMENT
IMPACT FEES MAY STILL BE
DIFFICULT TO COMPREHEND OR
INCONSISTENT, DEPENDING ON THE
JURISDICTION TO ADDRESS THE
INCONSISTENCIES, AB 3012
REQUIRES HCD TO DEVELOP A FEE
SCHEDULE, TEMPLATE, AND LIST OF
BEST PRACTICES THAT
JURISDICTIONS CAN UTILIZE THAT
WILL MAKE IT EASIER FOR BUILDERS
TO UNDERSTAND THE POTENTIAL
FEES, AND ALSO THE FEES THAT
THEY WOULD ENCOUNTER DURING THE
DEVELOPMENT PROCESS.
ADDITIONALLY, AB 3012 WILL ALSO
REQUIRE THAT JURISDICTIONS
PROVIDE A FEE ESTIMATE
CALCULATOR BY 2032. THIS WILL
HELP ENSURE THAT BUILDERS CAN
ARRIVE AT A MORE ACCURATE
ESTIMATE FOR THE FEES THAT ARE
REQUIRED DURING THE DEVELOPMENT
PROCESS. THIS BILL WILL ALSO
ENSURE THAT IMPACT FEE
INFORMATION IS ACCURATE AND EASY
TO UNDERSTAND. THAT'S IT. DO YOU
HAVE ANY WITNESSES WITH YOU
TODAY? AND I DON'T BELIEVE WE
HAVE WITNESSES WITH US TODAY.
OKAY KEEP IT SIMPLE. ALL RIGHT.
GREAT, ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF AB
3012, PLEASE COME UP. AND YOUR
NAME AND ORGANIZATION, I'M SORRY
. TALK INTO IT A LITTLE BIT
MORE. HOLLY FOR RENEE. DE. JESUS
WITH LIGHTHOUSE PUBLIC AFFAIRS
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION, SPUR EDEN HOUSING
AND CIVIC WELL, THANK YOU, RAFA
SONNENFELD WITH ENP ACTION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, RICK
PRITCHARD ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA YIMBY IN SUPPORT,
STEVEN SANDLER WITH BROWNSTEIN
ON BEHALF OF THE HOUSING ACTION
COALITION IN SUPPORT. THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR HIS WORK ON THIS
ISSUE. REBECCA MARCUS,
REPRESENTING LEADINGAGE
CALIFORNIA, IN SUPPORT. ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT SEEING NONE.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION IN NOBODY.
NOBODY IN OPPOSITION COME TO THE
DAIS. ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS?
YES. SENATOR GLASER, THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. I JUST WANTED TO,
THANK, ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON
FOR HIS HIS, REAL LEADERSHIP IN
THIS SPACE OVER MANY, MANY
YEARS, AS HE MENTIONED IN HIS
TESTIMONY, THIS HAS BEEN A
CHALLENGE, A SURPRISINGLY
CHALLENGING SPACE TO ACTUALLY
HAVE JUST DISCLOSURE AND
TRANSPARENCY. BUT IT IS SO
IMPORTANT IN BUILDING HOUSING TO
HAVE AN HONEST ASSESSMENT OF
WHAT THINGS REALLY ARE GOING TO
COST. AND THAT'S AT THE HEART OF
WHAT THIS MEASURE CONTINUES TO
DO, IT AND IT'S SOMETHING I'M
VERY PLEASED THAT YOU'RE
CONTINUING THIS LEADERSHIP IN
THIS SPACE, NOT GIVING UP, NOT
JUST DOING INCREMENTAL, BUT
KEEPING GOING UNTIL YOU CAN GET
THIS WORK DONE COMPLETELY. SO
THANK YOU FOR THAT. THANK YOU
SIR. MORE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE, WE WILL TAKE IT UP
WHEN WE HAVE ESTABLISHED A
QUORUM. THANK YOU. CLOSING
REMARKS. I'M SORRY. OH,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE. WE WILL
BE SUPPORTING YOU, NEXT, I SEE
THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY IS
HERE. WE'LL GO BACK TO AB 2427.
OKAY. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS, THIS IS A
BILL FOCUSED ON, ELECTRIC
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE IN
CALIFORNIA, FIRST, I WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE AND YOUR
TEAM FOR WORKING WITH US. AND,
YES, I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS, AS YOU
KNOW, WE NEED TO GREATLY ENHANCE
OUR CHARGING CAPACITY TO REACH
OUR GOALS FOR MORE EVS ON THE
ROAD, AS WELL AS OUR QUEST TO,
FOCUS ON OUR CLIMATE ISSUES AND
AIR QUALITY ISSUES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA, SO MANY INDIVIDUALS,
OF COURSE, CHARGE AT AT HOME.
SOME PEOPLE CHARGE AT CHARGING
STATIONS AT, AT THE MALL OR, YOU
KNOW, RETAIL ESTABLISHMENTS.
SOME PEOPLE LIVE IN APARTMENTS.
THEY DON'T HAVE A GARAGE. IT'S
NOT EASY FOR THEM. AND SO MORE
AND MORE, WE WANT TO SEE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE TO HAVE
CURBSIDE CHARGING. AND WE HAVE
TAKEN GREAT STEPS TO STREAMLINE
EFFORTS FOR CHARGING STATIONS
THROUGH RETAIL ESTABLISHMENTS,
BUT WE HAVEN'T FOCUSED ON DOING
THAT ON CURBSIDE CHARGING. SO
WITH US TODAY IS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO DO JUST THAT. WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH, LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND THE COALITION SUPPORTED
THIS, TRYING TO FIND A FAIR AND
BALANCED, APPROACH THAT
ADDRESSES ISSUES, BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT SO FAR, NO. NO VOTES.
ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE WITH ME
TODAY IS FLOW, A SUPPORTER OF
THE BILL. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. DAN CHAR WITH
OMNI GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
REPRESENTING FLOW EV CHARGING IN
SUPPORT AT FOUNDED IN 2009.
FLOWS AND EV CHARGING STATION
MANUFACTURER AND NETWORK
OPERATOR. WE HAVE DEPLOYED OVER
100,000 RESIDENTIAL, PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE EV CHARGING STATIONS
ACROSS NORTH AMERICA. WE ALSO
SPECIALIZE IN CURBSIDE CHARGING
SOLUTIONS. WE HAVE THE LARGEST
DEPLOYED ON THE CONTINENT, WITH
OVER 1000. IN QUEBEC, 100IN NEW
YORK CITY AND APPROXIMATELY
500IN THE CITY OF LA, THOSE US
NUMBERS AREN'T VERY LARGE. 100
NEW YORK CITY AND A 500 IN LA,
IT GOES TO SHOW THE HUGE
POTENTIAL THAT CURBSIDE HAS IN
IN THIS STATE AND NATIONALLY. WE
CAN ATTEST FIRSTHAND TO THREE
BENEFITS OF CURBSIDE CHARGERS
LEVERAGING BY LEVERAGING THE
PUBLIC RIGHT OF WAY, WE CAN
DEPLOY IN AREAS THAT HAVE
HISTORICALLY LACKED ACCESS TO
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE. THESE
CHARGERS CAN FURTHER DRIVE EV
ADOPTION BASED ON EXISTING
DEPLOYMENTS. WE HAVE SEEN
CHARGING UTILIZATION STEADILY
INCREASE. IN FACT, WE HAVE FOUND
THAT OUR LEVEL TWO CURBSIDE
CHARGERS HAVE SOME OF THE
HIGHEST UTILIZATION RATES OF OUR
ENTIRE PUBLIC CHARGING NETWORK,
IN PART BECAUSE THEY ARE LOCATED
IN DOWNTOWN CORES AND CLOSE OR
CLOSE TO MULTIFAMILY HOUSING,
THESE LEVEL TWO CHARGERS CAN
ALSO REDUCE DRIVERS DEPENDANCE
ON DC FAST CHARGERS, WHICH ARE
MORE EXPENSIVE, DEVELOP MORE
EXPENSIVE OF A CHARGE ON A PER
SESSION BASIS. CURBSIDE CHARGERS
CAN REDUCE DRIVING COSTS FOR
DRIVERS, REDUCE COST DISPARITIES
FOR THOSE THAT DON'T HAVE ACCESS
TO HOME CHARGING. AND DEVELOPERS
CAN ALSO REALIZE COST SAVINGS
BECAUSE IF YOU INSTALL IT ON A
LIGHT POLE OR A UTILITY POLE,
YOU REALLY MINIMIZE THOSE
DEVELOPMENT COSTS. SO WE WANT TO
MAXIMIZE THESE BENEFITS TO
CALIFORNIA DRIVERS. UNLIKE IN
OTHER COUNTRIES WITH RELATIVELY
HIGH EV PENETRATION, THIS IS THE
LOW HANGING FRUIT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. WE WANT TO MEET
DRIVERS WHERE THEY PARK. I'LL
KEEP IT SHORT AND LET THE, THE
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR YOUR
AYE VOTE JUST IN TIME. THANK YOU
, ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OF AB
2427, PLEASE? JULIE MALINOWSKI
BALL, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION,
CALTECH IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
MEGAN MCCLURG IN SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF THE EV CHARGING
ASSOCIATION, VALLEY CLEAN AIR
NOW AND CALSTART. THANK YOU,
ALYSSA SALEHI, ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF FOSTER CITY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. MICHELLE CARNALIS, ON
BEHALF OF UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT?
SEEING NONE. ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION? SEEING NONE. ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS? MEMBERS.
YES. SENATOR GLASER, I WANT TO
THANK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD, AND
I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT TODAY.
BUT I DO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
WHEN YOU HAVE A PRIVATE ENTITY
WHO'S A SPONSOR OF A BILL THAT
COULD PROFIT FROM THE BILL TO
MAKE IT CLEAR THAT THE
MARKETPLACE IS A WIDE OPEN
SPACE, THAT THIS DOESN'T PROVIDE
ANY, ANY UNIQUE PATHWAY FOR ONE
PARTICULAR COMPANY VERSUS
OTHERS. I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT COULD BE PUT ON THE RECORD
FROM FROM THE AUTHOR. OKAY YEAH.
NO, I TOTALLY AGREE, YOU KNOW,
THE MORE THE MERRIER, DOING
THIS, THERE ARE SOME COMPANIES
THAT STEPPED UP AND JUST LIKE,
YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU GO TO A
SHOPPING MALL WITH ELECTRIFY
AMERICA, CERTAINLY TESLA, BUT
OTHERS COULD COME ALONG THE WAY
AND DO THE SAME AND SAME WITH
WITH CURBSIDE. WE NEED WAY MORE
ENTITIES. STEPPING UP IN THE
MARKET ARE GOING TO COME
ANYWHERE CLOSE TO REACHING OUR
GOALS. YOU KNOW, THE MAJORITY OF
PEOPLE CHARGE FROM HOME RIGHT
NOW AND YOU KNOW, ONLY ONE IN AS
ANALYSIS SAYS, 1 IN 3, 1 IN 4
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE IN
APARTMENTS HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY
TO DO SO. SO YOU KNOW, THOSE
INDIVIDUALS START, YOU KNOW,
BUYING MORE EVS, YOU KNOW, WE
NEED MAKE IT, OPERABLE FOR THEM
TO, TO DO CURBSIDE. SO THANK YOU
. YES. SO THERE ARE MANY
COMPANIES INVOLVED IN BEING ABLE
TO PROVIDE THE SERVICES IN WHICH
YOUR BILL WOULD ALLOW. THAT'S
THAT'S JUST THE QUESTION.
CORRECT? ABSOLUTELY. YES. THANK
YOU. I'M HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK
YOU. I JUST HAVE JUST ONE
QUESTION THAT OCCURRED TO ME,
BECAUSE THERE'S SO MANY OTHER
BILLS DEALING WITH PARKING. WHAT
HAS BEEN THE EXPERIENCE OF THE
IMPACT ON CURBS ON PARKING, BY
MAKING THAT MAKING THE CHARGER
AVAILABLE CURBSIDE, HOW DOES IT
HOW HAS IT IMPACTED THE
DECREASING NUMBER OR DECREASING
SPACE FOR PARKING? I THINK
THERE'S A PILOT IN YOUR AREA,
LOS ANGELES, THAT WE CAN TALK, I
CAN ASK THE WITNESS TO. OKAY,
OKAY. THE CITY OF L.A. HAS, IN
FACT, PARTNERED WITH WITH US TO
DEPLOY OVER FIVE OVER, OVER, I
THINK 500 IN THE CITY OF L.A.
AND JUST AS A SIDE NOTE TO
SENATOR GLASER'S QUESTION, WE
DON'T OWN THOSE CHARGES.
ACTUALLY, THE CITY DOES. SO
THERE ARE BUSINESS MODELS THAT
WOULD INCLUDE PUBLIC ENTITIES IN
THE SPACES. THE ADDRESSABLE
MARKET IS SO HUGE IN THIS SPACE
THAT THAT, YOU KNOW, AS, AS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S SAID, WE'LL
TAKE ANY AND ALL INTEREST,
INCLUDING FROM THE PUBLIC SECTOR
, I DON'T KNOW THE SPECIFIC
ANSWER TO YOUR QUESTION, MADAM
CHAIR, CERTAINLY. WE'LL GET BACK
TO YOU ON ON THAT. I'M I BELIEVE
THE CITY DOES HAVE A TIME
LIMITATION ON ON SOME OF THOSE
CHARGERS. YOU KNOW, THE, THE,
COST, COST AND CAPACITY OF THE
CHARGER. HOW MUCH THEY COULD GET
IN A PARTICULAR DAY, SORT OF OUR
SELF LIMITERS ON HOW MUCH YOU
CAN ACTUALLY HOW MUCH TIME YOU
ACTUALLY CAN PLACE. BUT LET ME
LET ME GET BACK TO YOU ON THE
ACTUAL IMPACT ON, GENERAL
PARKING AVAILABILITY. OKAY.
GREAT OKAY, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU HAVE ANY CLOSING REMARKS?
ASSEMBLYMAN? NO. THANK YOU FOR,
FOR WORKING WITH US. AND, YOU
KNOW, THIS IS A TRICKY ISSUE. WE
WANT TO RESPECT LOCAL CONTROL
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND PUBLIC
SAFETY, BUT IF WE'RE GOING TO,
YOU KNOW, GREATLY ENHANCE OUR,
OUR, YOU KNOW, EV ROLLOUT
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA, WE NEED
TO HAVE WAY MORE ALTERNATIVES
THAT WE HAVE NOW. AND THIS IS A
PIECE OF THE PUZZLE HAVING
APPROPRIATE CURBSIDE CHARGING
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU. OKAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND WE'LL TAKE THE
VOTE LATER WHEN WE HAVE OUR
QUORUM, NEXT WE HAVE WHO'S HERE?
OH, SORRY, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HANEY, YOU READY? OKAY. AND YOU
WILL BE PRESENTING AB 3068. YES
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS, I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
DILIGENT WORK AND WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE'S
AMENDMENTS TODAY. AB 3068 IS THE
OFFICE TO HOUSING CONVERSION
ACT, WHICH WILL ACCELERATE
PRODUCTS, PROJECTS. THIS BILL IS
A DIRECT RESPONSE TO THE CRISIS
OF CALIFORNIA'S EMPTY DOWNTOWN
BUSINESS DISTRICTS, AND THE NEED
TO CONVERT UNDERUTILIZED OFFICE
BUILDINGS WITHIN PRIME LOCATIONS
TO NEW HOUSING. DOWNTOWNS ARE
STRUGGLING AS OUR WORK CULTURE
SHIFTS TOWARD REMOTE AND HYBRID
WORK POLICIES. WITH FEWER
EMPLOYEES WORKING FULL TIME IN
THE OFFICE, COMMERCIAL BUILDINGS
IN DOWNTOWNS ACROSS THE STATE
ARE EXPERIENCING THE EFFECTS OF
HIGH VACANCY RATES AND LOW FOOT
TRAFFIC. THIS SHIFT HAS LEFT
DOWNTOWNS IN TROUBLE AND IN
DESPERATE NEED OF CATALYTIC AND
INNOVATIVE TRANSFORMATIONS THAT
WILL CREATE LIVABLE
NEIGHBORHOODS IN OUR COMMERCIAL
DISTRICTS. TO HELP OUR DOWNTOWNS
AND BUILD MORE HOUSING. AB 3068
CREATES A PATHWAY FOR, BY RIGHT
MINISTERIAL APPROVAL OF OFFICE
CONVERSION PRODUCTS, ENSURING
MORE PREDICTABILITY AND FEWER
BARRIERS TO AN ALREADY DIFFICULT
BUILDING PROCESS. IT ALSO
PROVIDES FLEXIBILITY NEEDED TO
ENSURE THAT HISTORIC BUILDINGS
ARE MORE ECONOMICALLY FEASIBLE
FOR CONVERSION, SO THAT WE CAN
PRESERVE OUR BUILDINGS FOR
HOUSING WHILE MAKING SURE THE
DOWNTOWN'S DIVERSE
CHARACTERISTIC ARE KEPT INTACT.
I AGAIN WANT TO APPRECIATE THE
WORK OF THE COMMITTEE. I KNOW
THAT THERE'S SOME CONTINUING
CONVERSATIONS THAT ARE HAPPENING
AROUND THE LABOR LANGUAGE IN
THIS BILL, AND I WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THE CHAIR KNOWS THAT I'M
FULLY COMMITTED TO ENGAGING ALL
OF THE IMPACTED FOLKS AND MAKING
SURE AS THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD,
THAT WE ADDRESS THOSE NEEDS AND
COME TOGETHER FOR A COMPROMISE
WITH ME IN SUPPORT TODAY IS RAFA
SONNENFELD FROM YIMBY ACTION AND
CINDY HEITZMAN FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PRESERVATION
FOUNDATION, GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. YIMBY. ACTION IN
OUR CHAPTERS FIGHT FOR BETTER
HOUSING POLICIES BECAUSE WE WANT
TO REDUCE POVERTY AND
HOMELESSNESS, ELIMINATE RACIAL
SEGREGATION, CREATE JOBS, AND
STOP CLIMATE CHANGE, AS,
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HANEY MENTIONED,
WE'RE SEEING, A GENERATIONAL
SHIFT IN, IN WORK CULTURE WITH,
RECORD HIGH OFFICE VACANCY
RATES, OVER 35% VACANCY IN
DOWNTOWN SAN FRANCISCO, NEARLY
30% VACANCY IN GREATER LOS
ANGELES, CONVERTING VACANT
COMMERCIAL SPACE INTO
RESIDENTIAL HOUSING THROUGH
ADAPTIVE REUSE CAN REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF UNDERUTILIZED AND
VACANT BUILDINGS THAT HAVE BEEN
DECREASING IN VALUE VALUE,
THEREBY HELPING TO STABILIZE THE
COMMERCIAL REAL ESTATE MARKET
AND FILLING THOSE SPACES WITH
MORE VALUABLE TAX GENERATING
USES. ADAPTIVE REUSE PROJECTS
CAN ALSO INCREASE ACTIVITY AND
FOOT TRAFFIC IN NEIGHBORHOODS
ACROSS THE STATE, HELPING
SUPPORT LOCAL BUSINESSES AND
ENHANCING THE CULTURAL LIFE OF
CITIES AND TOWNS, UNFORTUNATELY,
LOCAL DISCRETIONARY APPROVAL
PROCESSES AND ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEWS FOR HOUSING CAN CAUSE
YEARS LONG DELAYS, INCREASED
RISK TO DEVELOPMENTS, AND MAKE
HOUSING PROJECTS INFEASIBLE AND
CONTRIBUTE TO THE CHALLENGES IN
RESOLVING THE STATE'S HOUSING
CRISIS. AB 3068 THE OFFICE OF
HOUSING CONVERSION ACT PROVIDES
A STREAMLINED MINISTERIAL
APPROVAL PROCESS FOR ADAPTIVE
REUSE OF EXISTING BUILDINGS INTO
RESIDENTIAL USES IN INFILL AREAS
IN ALL ZONES. THE ACT
FACILITATES THE CONVERSION OF
UNDERUTILIZED SPACE IN OFFICE
AND OTHER COMMERCIAL AND
INDUSTRIAL BUILDINGS INTO
RESIDENTIAL USES. IF AT LEAST
50% OF THE CONVERTED SPACE IS
USED FOR RESIDENTIAL, WHILE
OTHERWISE ALLOWS IT, ALLOWING
THOSE BUILDINGS TO MAINTAIN
THEIR CURRENTLY ALLOWED USES
WITHOUT THE NEED FOR RISKY,
LENGTHY DISCRETIONARY REZONING.
THE ACT ALSO PROTECTS HISTORIC
PROPERTIES, ENSURING THEIR
ADAPTIVE REUSE IS DONE IN
ACCORDANCE WITH NATIONAL BEST
PRACTICES FOR HISTORIC
PRESERVATION, AND IT AUTHORIZES
LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES TO CREATE A
PROPERTY TAX REBATE INCENTIVE
PROGRAM TO ENCOURAGE ADAPTIVE
REUSE PROJECTS. THANK YOU. I'M
AVAILABLE FOR ANY QUESTIONS.
YEAH ANY OTHER DO YOU HAVE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES? OKAY. WELCOME.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. THANK
YOU. AND GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
D'ABRUZZO COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS CINDY HEITZMAN, AND I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA PRESERVATION
FOUNDATION, A FOUNDATION
COMMITTED TO PROTECTING
CALIFORNIA'S RICH HISTORIC AND
CULTURAL HERITAGE THROUGH
ADVOCACY AND EDUCATION. TODAY,
I'M HERE TO SEEK YOUR SUPPORT
FOR AB 3068 LEGISLATION AUTHORED
BY ASSEMBLYMAN MATT HANEY AND
CO-SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
PRESERVATION FOUNDATION AND
YIMBY ACTION. WHAT SETS AB 3068
APART IS ITS STREAMLINED REVIEW
OF HISTORIC RESOURCES DESIGNED
TO CONVERT COMMERCIAL SPACES
INTO HOUSING WHILE PRESERVING
THOSE PORTIONS OR FEATURES THAT
CONVEY A BUILDING'S HISTORIC
COLOR, NATURAL OR ARCHITECTURAL
VALUES. THE REVIEW PROCESS
CONSIDERS FACTORS LIKE THE AGE
OF THE BUILDING, ITS LANDMARK
STATUS, AND UTILIZATION OF
FEDERAL OR STATE HISTORIC TAX
CREDITS. FURTHERMORE, IT
MANDATES COMPLIANCE WITH THE
SECRETARY OF THE INTERIOR
STANDARDS FOR THE TREATMENT OF
HISTORIC PROPERTIES, ENSURING
THAT PRESERVATION STANDARDS ARE
MET. WHY IS THIS IMPORTANT?
BECAUSE MANY OF THE BUILDINGS
THAT ARE THE BEST CANDIDATES FOR
ADAPTIVE REUSE ARE HISTORIC.
WE'VE SEEN NUMEROUS SUCCESS
STORIES OF ADAPTIVE REUSE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA, FROM OFFICES TO
HOSPITALS, FACTORIES, AND EVEN
FUNERAL HOMES REPURPOSED INTO
HOUSING. MOST NOTABLY, THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES. ADAPTIVE REUSE
ORDINANCE HAS REVITALIZED THIS
HISTORIC CITY CORE, GENERATING
OVER 12,000 NEW UNITS OF HOUSING
SINCE ITS ADOPTION IN 1999.
ADAPTIVE REUSE IS PART OF THE
PRESERVATIONIST DNA IN
SACRAMENTO. BUILDINGS LIKE GLOBE
MILLS, A FORMER FLOUR MILL, NOW
SERVES AS SENIOR HOUSING. THE
WAREHOUSE ARTISTS LOFTS, A
FORMER FURNITURE WAREHOUSE, IS
NOW A MIXED USE, TRANSIT
ORIENTED COMMUNITY FOR
SACRAMENTO AREA ARTISTS AND THE
1911 CAPITOL PARK HOTEL, ONE
BLOCK FROM THIS CAPITOL HAS BEEN
TRANSFORMED INTO PERMANENT
HOUSING FOR THE HOMELESS, USING
FEDERAL HISTORIC TAX CREDITS, IF
YOU COULD. AB 3068 IS A CATALYST
FOR ECONOMIC REVITALIZATION,
ALLEVIATING HOUSING SHORTAGES
AND SAFEGUARDING THE CHARACTER
OF OUR HISTORIC DOWNTOWNS, AND
IT IS A BLUEPRINT FOR
SUSTAINABLE DEVELOPMENT,
HARMONIZING ECONOMIC GROWTH WITH
HISTORIC PRESERVATION. THÀNH.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT OF AB 368? WOULD
YOU COME UP TO THE MICROPHONE
AND YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION?
HELLO. BROOKE PRITCHARD ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA YIMBY AND
SUPPORT FOR MEANING TO THE
LIGHTHOUSE PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON
BEHALF OF SPUR BUCKEYE
PROPERTIES AND CIVIC WELL IN
SUPPORT DON WILCOX WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CONFERENCE OF
CARPENTERS AND STRONG SUPPORT ON
THIS ONE. THANKS BOB WHITFIELD,
SOUTHERN COMPANY IN SUPPORT.
KIRSTEN BLATT ON BEHALF OF
STREETS FOR ALL IN SUPPORT.
REBECCA MARCUS ON BEHALF OF
LEADINGAGE, CALIFORNIA, IN
SUPPORT. OKAY. SEEING NO MORE IN
OPPOSITION. IN SUPPORT. ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION. GOOD MORNING.
CHAIR MEMBERS. BRADY GORDON, ON
BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES AND
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED, POSITION FIRST WANTED
TO THANK THE AUTHORS OFFICE AND
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE
AMENDMENTS. WE THINK THE BILL IS
MOVING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION,
BUT WE DO STILL HAVE CONCERNS
WITH THE MINISTERIAL ASPECTS OF
THE BILL BEING THE CONCERN THAT
THE DEVELOPMENT IS OCCURRING IN
AREAS THAT WERE NOT MEANT FOR
RESIDENTIAL USE. WE'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE ABILITY OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO PLAN FOR THAT,
AND DO WHAT IS NEEDED, AND
MINISTERIAL APPROVAL WOULD
EXEMPT THOSE AND PROVIDE, YOU
KNOW, UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
AND HARM A LOT OF OUR CITIES. SO
RESPECTFULLY, HAVING OPPOSED,
UNLESS AMENDED, POSITION, BUT
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK AND LOOK
FORWARD TO THOSE CONTINUED
CONVERSATIONS. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. YES GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
MEMBERS ANTHONY TANNEHILL WITH
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION. WE HAVEN'T OPPOSED
ALSO, REGARDING MORE OF THE
IMPACT FEE ISSUE AND LOOKING AT
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. SO I
VERY ENCOURAGED AND LOOK FORWARD
TO SHARING THAT WITH MY
ORGANIZATION. AND REPORTING BACK
TO THE AUTHOR AND THE COMMITTEE.
GREAT. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT,
MEMBERS, ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS? YES SENATOR GLASER,
THANK YOU. ASSEMBLYMAN I YOUR
HEART'S IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
FOR THE WORK YOU HAVE BEEN DOING
TO TRY TO IMPROVE THE
AVAILABILITY OF HOUSING IN OUR
STATE, AND YOU'RE TO BE
COMMENDED FOR THAT. I KNOW THAT,
YOU KNOW, AND MY COLLEAGUE ON MY
RIGHT KNOWS MY LOCAL LOCAL
CONTROL. PROCLIVITIES. BUT LET
ME, YOU KNOW, IN YOUR IN YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY, YOU TALKED
ABOUT DOWNTOWNS AND DOWNTOWNS
AND I THINK HE MIGHT HAVE SAID
IT 2 OR 3 TIMES, AND WHILE I
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU PROBABLY
HAVE THE VOTES TO MOVE THIS BILL
ALONG, WHY NOT FOCUS ON THE BIG
DOWNTOWN SAN FRANCISCO, SAN
JOSE, THAT REALLY WHERE YOUR
BILL REALLY IS FOCUSED AND LEAVE
SOME OF OUR SUBURBAN COMMUNITIES
THAT DON'T APPLY MAYBE COULD,
OUT OF OUT OF THIS MIX BECAUSE I
THINK THAT YOUR CONCERNS THAT
YOU, I THINK AT YOUR HEART ARE
THESE BIG URBAN DOWNTOWNS THAT
AREN'T DOING THIS, THAT CREATE
BARRIERS. AND SO THAT WOULD BE
SOMETHING THAT I, I DON'T THINK
YOU NEED THE VOTES HERE, IT
WOULD CERTAINLY MAKE FOLKS LIKE
ME WHO SEE OUR SUBURBAN
COMMUNITIES BE PICKED ON ALL THE
TIME, A LITTLE LESS ANXIOUS
ABOUT A BILL LIKE YOURS. OKAY.
ANY OTHER, DID YOU WANT TO
RESPOND OR. I APPRECIATE THAT.
WE DID LIMIT IT IN SOME WAYS TO,
SORT OF COMMERCIAL DISTRICTS.
AND I'M SURE THERE ARE MANY,
AREAS ACROSS THE STATE THAT ARE
TECHNICALLY SUBURBAN AREAS, BUT
HAVE DOWNTOWNS WHERE THERE ARE
THESE CHALLENGES AND ALSO THESE
OPPORTUNITIES WHERE YOU HAVE
BUILT, COMMERCIAL OFFICE
BUILDINGS THAT HAVE BEEN VACANT,
WHERE THEY DO NEED SOME
ADDITIONAL HOUSING. AND SO WE
HAVE LIMITED IT IN SOME WAYS.
BUT I THINK THAT THE OPPORTUNITY
DOES EXIST MORE THAN, THAN JUST
IN SAN FRANCISCO AND LA. AND SO
WE SORT OF TRIED TO DEFINE IT IN
A WAY THAT REFLECTS WHERE THE
NEED IS. BUT I APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING. AND TAKE THOSE
COMMENTS AND CONCERNS. GREAT,
WELL, WE APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK
THAT YOU'RE PUTTING IN WITH OUR,
WITH THE COMMITTEE STAFF AND THE
AMENDMENTS. AND I NOTE THAT ONE
OF THOSE AMENDMENTS HAS TO DO
WITH, EXPLICITLY REQUIRE,
PROJECTS TO BE CONSISTENT WITH
LOCAL ORDINANCES, SO THAT I
PARTIALLY, HOPEFULLY BEGINS TO
ADDRESS AND MY COLLEAGUES
CONCERN, FINAL REMARKS. THANK
YOU. AND TO THE FOLKS WHO WERE,
CONCERNS, I THINK WE DID. AND I
WANT TO THANK YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR, I THINK, ADDRESSING
AT LEAST SOME OF THOSE CONCERNS,
PARTICULARLY AROUND THE FEES AND
SUCH. AND WE WILL HAVE ONE MORE
POLICY COMMITTEE HERE, AND WE'LL
CONTINUE TO WORK ON ON THE
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. GREAT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE. NEXT WE HAVE, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CARRILLO. WENDY CARRILLO
AND, ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARRILLO
WILL BE PRESENTING A B 3177.
BUENOS DIAS. YES. SO, MORNING.
IT'S STILL MORNING. THANK GOD.
OKAY. WHICH NUMBERS? SO.
I'M THE OPPOSITE. OKAY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS, I
AM PROUD TO PRESENT A B 3177,
WHICH ESTABLISHES GUIDELINES ON
SPOT WIDENING, A PRACTICE IN
WHICH DEVELOPERS CEDE A PORTION
OF THEIR LAND ADJACENT TO THE
ROADWAY TO WIDEN IT WITHOUT
COMPENSATION. I'M HAPPY TO SAY
THAT OUR STAFFS WERE ABLE TO
WORK TOGETHER WITH YOUR
COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS, AND WE
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TODAY, MOVING ON.
THIS PRACTICE IS DONE IN A
HANDFUL OF JURISDICTIONS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA, OFTEN
RESULTING IN ROADS THAT
ESSENTIALLY ZIGZAG, PARCEL BY
PARCEL, FAILING TO MEET THE
INTENDED PURPOSES OF TRAFFIC
MITIGATION, AND FREQUENTLY
INDUCING FASTER AND OFTENTIMES
MORE DANGEROUS DRIVING. SPOT
WIDENING REQUIREMENTS
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE HOUSING
COSTS, ADDING SOMEWHERE BETWEEN
10,000 TO $50,000 PER HOUSING
UNIT, AMOUNTING TO HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS PER PROJECT. THIS
ADDITIONAL COST TRANSLATES
DIRECTLY INTO HIGHER RENTS UNDER
AND UNDERCUTTING HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY. MOREOVER, THESE
REQUIREMENTS REDUCE THE AMOUNT
OF LAND AVAILABLE FOR HOUSING,
LESSENING THE NUMBER OF FEASIBLE
UNITS ON A PROPERTY. LIKEWISE,
THE DEMANDS IMPOSED BY SPOT
WIDENING CAN MAKE MANY POTENTIAL
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS INFEASIBLE,
AS WAS THE CASE WITH A PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING PROJECT IN
LOS ANGELES THAT FOUGHT FOR
ALMOST TWO YEARS TO RECEIVE A
WAIVER. THIS BILL LIMITS THE
PRACTICE OF SPOT WIDENING BY
PROHIBITING A LOCAL GOVERNMENT
FROM IMPOSING A LAND DEDICATION
REQUIREMENT FOR A ROADWAY
WIDENING ON A HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT IN A TRANSIT
PRIORITY AREA, OR FOR
DEVELOPMENTS WITH STREET
FRONTAGE OF LESS THAN 500FT.
THIS BILL PROVIDES THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. THIS BILL PROVIDES
THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS MAY STILL
IMPOSE A LAND DEDICATION
REQUIREMENT ON HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS FOR TRAFFIC SAFETY
FEATURES. IF THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT MAKES A FINDING
SPECIFIC TO THE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT, SUPPORTED BY
SUBSTANTIAL EVIDENCE THAT THE
LAND DEDICATION REQUIREMENT IS
NECESSARY TO PRESERVE THE
HEALTH, SAFETY AND WELFARE OF
THE PUBLIC, SUBSTANTIAL EVIDENCE
IS THE LOWEST STANDARD
AVAILABLE. AS SUCH, THIS
PROVISION WILL PROVIDE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WITH FLEXIBILITY
WHERE NEEDED. ADDITIONALLY, AB
3177 REPLACES THE REFERENCE TO
TRANSIT STATION WITH TRANSIT
PRIORITY AREA WITHIN THE
MITIGATION FEE ACT, PROVIDING
REDUCED MITIGATION FEES FOR
HOUSING NEAR BUS STOPS AND
PLANNED TRANSIT STOPS WITHIN ONE
YEAR OF COMPLETION. EVEN WITH
THE LIMITED DEFINITION OF
TRANSIT STATION, THAT IS NOT
USED ELSEWHERE, AND STATE LAW
DOES NOT COVER THIS PROVISION OF
THE BILL AS WELL ARE WELL
ALIGNED WITH THE STATE'S GOALS
AND PRIORITIES TO INCENTIVIZE
NEW HOUSING DEVELOPMENT AND
CLIMATE SMART AREAS. THIS BILL
IS SPONSORED BY STREETS FOR ALL
AND SUPPORTED BY A COALITION OF
HOUSING ORGANIZATIONS THAT
ADVOCATE FOR BOTH MARKET RATE
AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING, AS WELL
AS ENVIRONMENTAL, STREET SAFETY
AND STREET SAFETY ORGANIZATIONS.
MOST IMPORTANTLY, THE BILL HAS
NO OPPOSITION. AND AGAIN, I'M
GRATEFUL THAT OUR YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF AND MY TEAM ARE ABLE TO
AND THE SPONSORS WERE ABLE TO,
COME UP WITH, WELL INTENDED
AMENDMENTS THAT MOVE THE BILL
FORWARD AND GRATEFUL FOR THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS CHRISTINE BLAD,
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF STATE
POLICY, AND MARK VUKOVICH,
DIRECTOR OF STATE POLICY FOR
STREETS FOR ALL. GREAT. THANK
YOU. YOU MAY GO AHEAD, MY NAME
IS KIRSTEN. I'M SORRY. I JUST
WANT TO REMIND YOU OF TWO
MINUTES. OKAY. MY NAME IS
KIRSTEN BLAD. AND I'M THE
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF STATE
POLICY FOR STREETS FOR ALL. THE
PROUD SPONSOR OF THIS BILL, OUR
BILL ENDS THE PRACTICE OF
REQUIRING A HOUSING DEVELOPER TO
GIVE UP POTENTIAL HOUSING LAND
TO PAY HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS FOR THE SOLE PURPOSE OF
WIDENING THE ROAD AS A CONDITION
OF APPROVAL FOR ENTITLEMENTS.
THIS PRACTICE, KNOWN AS SPOT
WIDENING, TAKES PRIVATE LAND
WITHOUT COMPENSATION FROM
HOUSING TO PUBLIC ROADS ON A PER
PROJECT BASIS, AND DOES NOT
ACHIEVE ITS OFTEN PURPORTED GOAL
OF TRAFFIC MITIGATION. BECAUSE
THE WIDENING IS LIMITED TO THE
ROADWAY ADJACENT TO THE PROJECT,
LEADING TO SENSELESS ROAD
CONFIGURATIONS THAT EXPAND AND
CONTRACT SEEMINGLY AT RANDOM.
AND IF YOU LOOK ON PAGE TWO OF
THE ORANGE HANDOUT WE PASSED
AROUND, YOU CAN SEE WHAT THIS
LOOKS LIKE IN PRACTICE IN LOS
ANGELES. SPOT WIDENING IS BASED
ON THE ANTIQUATED AND DISPROVEN
IDEA THAT WE CAN WIDEN OUR WAY
OUT OF TRAFFIC CONGESTION.
THROUGH THIS FUTILE ATTEMPT TO
REDUCE CONGESTION, WE ARE MAKING
OUR STREETS MORE DANGEROUS AND
OUR CITIES LESS LIVABLE, EVEN
SACRIFICING THE WIDTH OF THE
SIDEWALK IN SOME OF THESE CASES,
SPOT WIDENING TYPICALLY ACHIEVES
NOTHING MORE THAN AN INCREASED
WIDTH OF THE EXISTING TRAVEL
LANES FOR A VERY SHORT DISTANCE,
WHICH DOES NOTHING TO MITIGATE
CONGESTION. BUT WE DO BELIEVE
HAS THE EFFECT OF FACILITATING
COLLISIONS. AS RESEARCH FROM
JOHNS HOPKINS UNIVERSITY ON LATE
NIGHTS FOUND. I WANT TO ALSO
SHARE WHAT THIS IS LIKE ON THE
HOUSING SIDE. ONE PROJECT IN
L.A. LOST OVER 6000FT² OF LAND
TO ROAD WIDENING, WHICH MEANS
THEY LOST THE ABILITY TO BUILD
OVER 30 ADDITIONAL DWELLING
UNITS. AND THIS PROJECT WAS ON
TOP OF AN LÀ METRO STATION.
ANOTHER PROJECT, CONSISTING OF
100% HOMELESS HOUSING BY
NONPROFIT DEVELOPER, WAS DELAYED
FOR ALMOST TWO YEARS AFTER THEY
APPEALED THIS REQUIREMENT, AS
THEIR PROJECT WOULD NOT PENCIL
OTHERWISE IN THE TIME IT TOOK
FOR THE DEVELOPER TO OBTAIN A
WAIVER, AN ADDITIONAL 12,000
PEOPLE FELL INTO HOMELESSNESS IN
CALIFORNIA. SO IN SOME GOOD
GOVERNANCE, FOLKS SUPPORT OUR
BILL BECAUSE OUR GROWING
PAVEMENT MAINTENANCE BACKLOG IS
BANKRUPTING RURAL AND SUBURBAN
CITIES. ENVIRONMENTALISTS
SUPPORT THIS BILL BECAUSE SPOT
WIDENING RIPS UP MATURE TREES,
INDUCES MORE CAR TRIPS, AND
WORSENS THE WORSENS THE URBAN
HEAT ISLAND EFFECT MARKET RATE
AND AFFORDABLE DEVELOPERS ARE
SUPPORTIVE BECAUSE THIS POLICY
MAKES THEIR PROJECTS CHEAPER TO
FINANCE AND PENCIL. LASTLY, SAFE
STREETS GROUPS LIKE US ARE THE
SPONSORS BECAUSE THIS SORT OF
WIDENING JUST INDUCES DANGEROUS
SPEEDING THROUGH WIDER LANES.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. WRAP IT
UP. THAT'S ALL. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT GOOD MORNING.
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS MARK,
DIRECTOR OF STATE POLICY. I'VE
BEEN TOLD WE HAVE. IT'S OKAY IN
ADVANCE IF I READ PROFESSOR
MICHAEL MANVILLE'S TESTIMONY
THAT HE GAVE TO ASSEMBLY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE, BECAUSE
HE'S NOT PRESENT TODAY. HE WAS.
HE'S AT A WEDDING AT THE MOMENT.
JUST WANT TO CONFIRM THAT THAT'S
STILL OKAY. AS LONG AS IT'S
WITHIN TWO MINUTES. I'LL DO MY
BEST. I'LL READ FAST, HELLO? MY
NAME IS NOT PROFESSOR MICHAEL
MANVILLE. I'M A PROFESSOR OF
URBAN PLANNING AT UCLA AND THE
CHAIR OF OUR UCLA'S URBAN
PLANNING DEPARTMENT. I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL. I
HAVE STUDIED THE ORIGINS AND
OUTCOMES OF THIS LAW, THIS BILL
THAT THIS BILL TARGETS. I'M THE
AUTHOR OF THE PAPER THAT HAS
BEEN DISTRIBUTED. SO I GUESS I
CAN SAY THESE REGULATIONS ARE
AMONG THE MOST UNUSUAL AND LEAST
EFFICIENT REGULATIONS I'VE EVER
ENCOUNTERED. THEY HAVE VERY FEW
BENEFITS. THEIR NOMINAL GOAL IS
TO REDUCE TRAFFIC CONGESTION,
WHICH THEY DO NOT DO, AND IN
MANY CIRCUMSTANCES THEY
EXACERBATE CONGESTION BY
CREATING BOTTLENECKS AND
IRREGULAR STREET ALIGNMENTS. AND
THEY DO EXACERBATE THE HOUSING
CRISIS, BECAUSE THE COST OF
THESE WIDENINGS REMOVES LAND
FROM HOUSING DEVELOPMENT AND
MAKES OUR AFFORDABILITY CRISIS
WORSE. A FURTHER POINT IS THAT
THESE LAWS, ONCE PUT INTO PLACE,
EXPERIENCE SHOWS US THAT THEY
ARE VERY DIFFICULT TO REFORM OR
REMOVE. AND SO I'LL JUST JUST
QUICKLY DESCRIBE THE PROBLEM
WITH THE LAW. THE NOMINAL GOAL
HERE IS TO REDUCE CONGESTION BY
WIDENING THE ROADS AND DECADES
OF RESEARCH OVERWHELMINGLY
SUGGESTS THAT WON'T WORK, THAT
THE WIDER STREET, DOES NOT MAKE
VEHICLES MOVE FASTER AT PEAK
HOURS. BUT THAT'S NOT EVEN THE
PROBLEM WITH THIS RULE. THE
PROBLEM WITH THIS RULE IS THAT
YOU ACTUALLY NEVER GET A WIDER
STREET, EVER, BECAUSE YOU'RE
DOING THIS ON A PIECEMEAL BASIS,
INCREMENTAL PARCEL BY PARCEL AT
A TIME. AND WHAT IT DOES IS
ACTUALLY CREATES BOTTLENECKS BY
GIVING SORTS OF THESE LITTLE
INCREMENTAL BUMP OUTS IN THE
STREETS THAT CREATES THESE
LITTLE BOTTLENECKS. IT CREATES
SAFETY PROBLEMS, IT CREATES
DRAINAGE PROBLEMS, IT CREATES
MAINTENANCE PROBLEMS. AND SO ON
AND SO ON. ADDING ROAD SPACE
INCREMENTALLY DOES NOT REDUCE
CONGESTION. TAKING SPACE IN
INCREMENTALLY FROM LAND FOR
HOUSING DOES, THOUGH, IMPINGE ON
AFFORDABILITY, BECAUSE THAT
SPACE IS ACTUALLY VERY IMPORTANT
TO THE FEASIBILITY OF A MARKET
RATE OR AFFORDABLE DEVELOPMENT.
SO AT BEST, MANY UNITS THAT
WOULD SAY, EXCUSE ME, AT BEST,
THE COST OF THIS WIDENING MAKES
IT SO THE DEVELOPER CAN CANNOT
BUILD AS MANY UNITS AS IT WOULD
PREFER. AND AT WORST, IT MAKES
THE DEVELOPMENT REDEVELOPMENT OF
THE PARCEL COMPLETELY IMPOSSIBLE
AND WHEN THE DEVELOPMENT IS
REDEVELOPED IS IMPOSSIBLE. YOU
NOT ONLY LOSE HOUSING, BUT
GUARANTEES THE LAW IS ACTUALLY
NEVER GOING TO DO WHAT IT'S
SUPPOSED TO DO, WHICH IS WIDEN
THE ENTIRE STREET. SO EVEN ON
ITS OWN TERMS, THE LAW IS
SELF-DEFEATING. THANK YOU. I'M
STILL HERE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
ON BEHALF OF STREETS FOR ALL,
NOT MICHAEL MANVILLE. OKAY I'M
GLAD YOU KEEP SAYING WHO YOU
REALLY ARE, WHO YOU ARE. OKAY.
THANK YOU. ANY MORE, WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF AB 3177, PLEASE
COME TO THE MIC. REBECCA MARCUS,
ON BEHALF OF LEADING EDGE
CALIFORNIA, MARK STIVERS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP AND SUPPORT.
CATHERINE CHARLES, ON BEHALF OF
HOUSING ACTION COALITION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, BROOKE
PRITCHARD, ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA YIMBY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, ANYONE SEE NO MORE IN
SUPPORT? ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO
AB 3177 SEEING NONE. QUESTIONS?
COMMENTS? COLLEAGUES THANK YOU
CHAIR, FOR INDULGING ME. YOU
DIDN'T WANT TO HAVE TO MAKE IT
MORE INTERESTING, MAKE IT MORE
INTERESTING, ASSEMBLY MEMBER I
YOU KNOW, I CAME INTO THE
HEARING TODAY NOT REALLY THAT
EXCITED ABOUT YOUR BILL BECAUSE
I'M A LOCAL CONTROL PERSON AND I
THINK IT DOES IMPINGE ON LOCAL
CONTROL. BUT AFTER HEARING THE
TESTIMONY AND LOOKING AT THE
MATERIALS, I THINK YOU REALLY
HAVE HIT ON SOMETHING THAT, IS
JUST AN UNFORTUNATE, YOU KNOW,
BUREAUCRACY OUT OF CONTROL KIND
OF A SITUATION WHERE IT JUST
DOESN'T, IT JUST DOESN'T ALL
COMPUTE. AND GIVEN THE EXTENT OF
THE HOUSING CRISIS WE'RE FACING
IN THE STATE, TO ME, IT'S A
PLACE WHERE I CAN CERTAINLY BACK
TO BE SUPPORTIVE OF THE WORK
THAT YOU ARE ADVANCING IN THIS
BILL. AND WITH THAT, I'M HAPPY
TO SUPPORT IT. THANK YOU, GREAT.
WELL, I ALSO WILL BE SUPPORTING
AND, PARTICULARLY BECAUSE EVEN
THOUGH AS YOU SAID, IT'S, THE
MOST OF MANY, MANY OF THE TIMES,
THE USE OF THIS, TOOL WAS NOT
DONE IN SUCH A WAY THAT WOULD
HELP HOUSING, BUT ACTUALLY HURT
HOUSING. BUT I DO THINK THAT IN
TERMS OF LOCAL CONTROL, THE
ISSUE OF TRAFFIC SAFETY SHOULD
REMAIN, AS, AS A CONSIDERATION
BY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. SO WITH
THAT AND OTHER AMENDMENTS, I
APPRECIATE WORKING TOGETHER WITH
YOU. AND, DO YOU HAVE ANY FINAL
REMARKS? I'LL USE YOUR
STATEMENTS AND THAT OF SENATOR
GLACIER AS MY CLOSE. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. RESPECTFULLY. REQUEST
AND I VOTE. OKAY GREAT. WE WILL
TAKE IT UP WHEN WE GET OUR
QUORUM. THANK YOU. YES. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WILSON, PLEASE COME UP.
WELCOME GOOD TO SEE YOU HERE.
AND LET'S SEE, WE'RE TAKING UP
AB 3259. YES. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR, SENATOR,
PLEASE, I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT
AB 3259, A DISTRICT BILL THAT
WOULD PROVIDE NEEDED FLEXIBILITY
FOR RESIDENTS IN SOLANO COUNTY
TO VOTE ON LOCAL REVENUE
MEASURES, MEASURES TO PROTECT
ESSENTIAL SERVICES AND IMPROVE
CRITICAL TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE, SPECIFICALLY,
THIS BILL WOULD RAISE THE
STATUTORY TRANSACTION AND USE
TAX LIMIT ABOVE THE 2% CAP TO
ALLOW CITIES WITHIN SOLANO
COUNTY TO VOTE ON MEASURES THAT
RAISE LOCAL REVENUE AT A RATE
NOT TO EXCEED 0.5. WITH A SUNSET
IN 2029. CURRENTLY, A CITIZEN
INITIATIVE PUT ON THE BALLOT BY
RESIDENTS IN THE CITY OF BENICIA
WOULD, IF APPROVED BY VOTERS,
PUT THE CITY ABOVE THE CAP.
EARLIER THIS YEAR, VOTERS IN THE
CITY OF BENICIA OVERWHELMINGLY
APPROVED A THREE QUARTER CENT
GENERAL PURPOSE SALES TAX
INCREASE TO SUPPORT PUBLIC
SAFETY AND ESSENTIAL SERVICES.
AT THE SAME TIME, RESIDENTS IN
BENICIA HAD FORMED A COALITION
TO DRAFT THE CITIZEN'S
INITIATIVE FOR THE NOVEMBER
BALLOT FOR THE SPECIFIC PURPOSE
OF INCREASING REVENUE TO IMPROVE
ROAD CONDITIONS. HOWEVER, WITH
THE RECENT SALES TAX INITIATIVE
APPROVED BY THE VOTERS, IF THE
NOVEMBER CITIZENS BALLOT
INITIATIVE WERE TO PASS, IT
WOULD THEN PUT THE CITY ABOVE
THE 2% COUNTY CAP. THIS BILL
DOES NOT RAISE OR ENACT ANY NEW
TAXES. Ã SIMPLY EMPOWERS VOTERS
WITHIN SOLANO COUNTY BY ALLOWING
THEM TO DECIDE WHETHER TO
APPROVE LOCAL REVENUE MEASURES
THAT WOULD EXCEED THE 2% CAP
UNTIL 2029. WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. GREAT. THANK YOU. DO YOU
HAVE ANY, SUPPORT WITNESSES? NOT
TODAY. OKAY, IS THERE ANYONE WHO
WANTS TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
3259, SEEING NONE. ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB 3259. OKAY.
SEEING NONE. COME ON. SENATOR
GLAZER. YES. NO. IT'S OKAY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP, FOR YOUR
COUNTY. YOU'VE BEEN A CHAMPION
AND THEY APPRECIATE IT AND WE
APPRECIATE IT TOO. I'M HAPPY TO
MOVE THE BILL AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. OKAY. ALL RIGHT. ANY
CLOSING REMARKS? YOU DID VERY
GOOD, CLOSING REMARKS. I
APPRECIATE THOSE COMMENTS. THANK
YOU. MADAM CHAIR, AND THE
SUPPORT OF THE STAFF WHO'S
WORKED ON THIS BILL AND PROVIDED
FEEDBACK. SO WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. GREAT.
I WILL BE SUPPORTING AND WE WILL
VOTE WHEN WE HAVE OUR QUORUM.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. SPEAKING
OF WHICH, SPEAKING OF WHICH.
WE'LL BE TAKING A RECESS FOR A
FEW MINUTES.
WE'LL GET BACK INTO SESSION
HERE, FIRST, WE NEED TO
ESTABLISH QUORUM. SENATORS
RUSSELL HERE. RUSSELL PRESENT.
SEYARTO. DOLLY. DOLLY. PRESENT
GLASER. GLASER. PRESENT.
SKINNER. WAHAB WIENER. WIENER.
PRESENT. YOU HAVE A QUORUM. NEED
A MOTION FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. SO MOVED BY SENATOR
DOLLY. MOTION IS ADOPTED.
CONSENT CALENDAR. SENATORS
DURAZZO I. DURAZZO I. SATO
DOLLY. DOLLY I GLASER. GLASER I
SKINNER. WAHAB WIENER WIENER I
40 ZERO. THANK YOU. THEN WE'LL
START WITH THE BILLS, FIRST ITEM
AB 930. DO WE HAVE A MOTION?
I'LL MOVE. SO EXCITED. OKAY, WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR GLASER.
PLEASE VOTE. MOTION IS TO PASS,
AS AMENDED, TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HOUSING. SENATORS DURAZZO I
DURAZZO I SATO. DOLLY. DOLLY. NO
GLASER. GLASER, I. SKINNER,
WAHAB. WIENER. WIENER I 3 TO 1.
THAT OPEN, GO ON TO ITEM NUMBER
TWO. AB 1889. MOTION IS TO PASS
A MOTION. A MOTION MOVED BY
SENATOR WIENER. MOTION IS TO
PASS, AS AMENDED, TO THE
COMMITTEE ON NATURAL RESOURCES
AND WATER. SENATOR DURAZZO I,
DURAZZO I. SATO. DOLLY GLASER.
SKINNER WAHAB WIENER WIENER I 2
TO 0. LEAVE THE VOTE OPEN. MOVE
ON TO ITEM NUMBER THREE. AB
2553. WE HAVE A MOTION MOVED BY
SENATOR GLASER. MOTION IS TO
PASS, AS AMENDED, TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HOUSING. SENATORS
DURAZZO. Ã. DURAZZO. AYE. SATO
DOLLY. GLASER. GLASER AYE.
SKINNER. WAHAB. WIENER WIENER.
AYE. 3 TO 0. THAT OPEN. ITEM
FOUR IS AB 2712. DO I HAVE A
MOTION? SENATOR GLASER, MOTION
IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED, TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HOUSING. SENATORS
DURAZZO I. DURAZZO AYE. SATO.
DOLLY. DOLLY. NO GLASER. GLASER.
AYE. SKINNER. WAHAB WIENER 2 TO
1. LEAVE THAT OPEN. NEXT IS ITEM
7500. I THOUGHT WE JUST SAID OH,
THAT WE JUST DID THAT. OKAY,
ITEM FIVE AB 1820. DO YOU HAVE A
MOTION MOVE MOVED BY SENATOR
DOLLY? MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HOUSING. SENATORS
DURAZZO I, DURAZZO I. SATO.
DOLLY DOLLY I GLASER. GLASER I
SKINNER. WAHAB WIENER WIENER I 4
TO 0. OKAY. MOVE ON TO ITEM
SEVEN. NØ EIGHT. THEY GOT
PULLED. OH THAT'S RIGHT. SORRY.
PULLED HERE. OKAY. ITEM EIGHT IS
AB 2427. DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON
MOVED BY SENATOR GLASER. MOTION
IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED, TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ENERGY, UTILITIES
AND COMMUNICATION. SENATORS
DURAZZO. DURAZZO. AYE. SATO.
DOLLY GLASER. GLASER. AYE.
SKINNER WAHAB. WIENER. WIENER.
AYE 3 TO 0. LEAVE THAT OPEN.
ITEM NINE. AB 2557. DO I HAVE A
MOTION? OKAY. WITH THE
AMENDMENTS? YES, YES, SHE. WE
SPECIFICALLY. OKAY. MOTION.
MOTION MADE BY SENATOR WIENER.
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO THE COMMITTEE ON LABOR,
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND
RETIREMENT. SENATOR DURAZZO I
DURAZZO. AYE. SATO DOLLY. DOLLY,
NO. GLASER. NO GLASER. NO.
SKINNER. WAHAB WIENER. WIENER.
AYE. DO YOU MIND GOING THROUGH.
OKAY. BILL NINE, ITEM NINE AB
TWO. OKAY. THANK YOU. WAHAB AYE.
THREE TO 3 TO 2. LEAVE THAT
OPEN, ITEM NUMBER TEN, AB 2661.
MOTION. I NEED A MOTION. THANK
YOU. MOVED BY SENATOR WAHAB.
MOTION IS TO PASS THE COMMITTEE
ON ENERGY, UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATIONS. SENATORS
DURAZZO. AYE DURAZZO. AYE. SATO.
DOLLY DOLLY. AYE. GLASER.
GLASER. AYE. SKINNER WAHAB.
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER WIENER. AYE.
5 TO 0. YOU GOT OPEN. MOVE ON TO
ITEM 12. AB 3259. DO YOU HAVE A
MOTION? I'LL MOVE IT. MOVED BY
SENATOR GLASER. MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE COMMITTEE ON REVENUE
AND TAXATION. SENATORS DURAZZO.
DURAZZO. AYE. SEYARTO. DOLLY.
DOLLY Â. NÓ. GLASER. GLASER.
AYE. SKINNER WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER HI. WIENER. AYE 41. DO
THAT. OPEN MOVING ON TO ITEM 14.
AB 3012. DO I HAVE A MOTION TO
MOVE? SENATOR WIENER MOTION IS
TO PASS, AS AMENDED, TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HOUSING. SENATORS
DURAZZO I DURAZZO I SATO. DOLLY.
DOLLY. AYE GLASER. GLASER. AYE.
SKINNER. WAHAB WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER. WIENER. AYE 5 TO 0. OKAY
MOVE ON. LEAVE THAT OPEN, ITEM
15, AB 3068. DO I HAVE A MOTION?
SENATOR WAHAB, THANK YOU. MOTION
IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED, TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HOUSING. SENATORS
DURAZZO I DURAZZO. AYE. SEYARTO
DOLLY. NO. DOLLY. NO GLASER.
GLASER. NO. SKINNER WAHAB.
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER WIENER. AYE.
3 TO 2. DO THAT. OPEN. MOVE ON
TO ITEM 16. AB 3177. DO I NEED A
DO I HAVE A MOTION? SENATOR
GLASER. MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HOUSING. SENATORS. DURAZZO.
DURAZZO. AYE. SATO SATO. NO.
DOLLY. DOLLY. NO. GLASER GLASER.
AYE. SKINNER. WAHAB FILE NUMBER
16. WAHAB. AYE. WIENER WIENER.
AYE 42. LEAVE THAT OPEN. OKAY.
SO THOSE ARE. YES. WE DID
CONSENT. SO ANYONE WHO VOTED ON
EVERYTHING. OKAY, WE'LL GO BACK.
YES, SENATOR. WE'LL GO BACK TO.
SO. YEAH. SO THEM THREE ARE GOOD
TO GO. AND THEN WE HAVE TO GO
BACK TO. ALL RIGHT. DO YOU WANT
TO DO CONSENT AND THEN GO DOWN.
YES OKAY. SO WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THE CONSENT WE GOT. OH, WE OH WE
HAVE OKAY. WE HAVE MOTIONS ON
ALL OF THEM. SORRY. OKAY VOTING
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR. SENATOR
SATO I SATO. AYE SKINNER. WAHAB.
WAHAB. AYE 6 TO 0. OKAY. ITEM
ONE AB 930. MOTION IS TO PASS,
AS AMENDED, TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HOUSING. CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 1
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATOR SATO. SATO NÓ SKINNER.
WAHAB. WHAT FILE NUMBER IS ONE?
ONE? I WAHAB I 42, LEAVE THAT
OPEN. ITEM NUMBER TWO. DO YOU
WANT TO. YEAH. ONE AGAIN AND
THEN GO THROUGH. YEAH. THAT'S
GONNA JUST WALKED IN. SHOULD WE
GO BACK TO ONE OKAY. LET HER
SETTLE IN AND THEN WE WILL HAVE
TO GO BACK. NICE AND. OKAY.
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK TO ITEM
ONE AB 930. MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED, TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HOUSING. CURRENT VOTE IS 42 WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATOR
SKINNER. SKINNER. AYE FIVE Dð TO
CLOSE THE BOOK. CLOSE THE VOTE,
ITEM TWO AB 1889. MOTION IS TO
PASS, AS AMENDED, TO THE
COMMITTEE ON NATURAL RESOURCES
AND WATER. CURRENT VOTE IS 2 TO
0, WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATOR. CIERTO. CIERTO? NO.
DOLLY GLAZER. SKINNER SAYS OH,
THEY DIDN'T KNOW. YES THEY
DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT IT. SKINNER.
AYE. WAHAB WAHAB. AYE. 41. 38.
OKAY. CLOSE THE VOTE. ITEM THREE
AB 2553. MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED, TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HOUSING. CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 0,
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATOR SAWYER TO SATO. NO.
DOLLY SKINNER TO SKINNER. AYE.
WAHAB. WAHAB AYE. 5 TO 1. CLOSE.
CLOSE THE VOTE. MOVE ON TO ITEM
FOUR, AB 2712. MOTION IS TO
PASS, AS AMENDED, TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HOUSING. CURRENT
VOTE IS 2 TO 1, WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. SENATOR. CIERTO.
CIERTO. NO. SKINNER SKINNER.
AYE. WAHAB WAHAB. AYE. WIENER
42. CLOSE THE VOTE. GO ON TO
ITEM FIVE. AB 1820. MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HOUSING. CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 0
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATOR SATO. SATO. AYE.
SKINNER. SKINNER AYE. WAHAB.
WAHAB. AYE. SEVEN ZERO. CLOSE
THE VOTE. MOVE ON TO ITEM FIVE.
DID WE JUST THAT WE JUST DID
FIVE. THAT WAS FIVE. OKAY. ITEM.
7808I KEEP SEEING THAT. OKAY
ITEM EIGHT AB 2427. WHAT
HAPPENED IS MOTION IS TO PASS,
AS AMENDED, TO THE COMMITTEE ON
ENERGY, UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATION. CURRENT VOTE IS 3
TO 0 WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATOR SATO, WHICH ONE ARE WE
ON? I EIGHT AB 2427. THANK YOU.
NOT VOTING. DOLLY SKINNER.
SKINNER. AYE. WAHAB I JUST WANT
TO MAKE SURE WE'RE FILE NUMBER
EIGHT. EIGHT. OKAY. WAHAB. AYE.
FIVE 5 TO 0. CLOSE THE RULES.
ITEM NINE AB 2557. MOTION IS TO
PASS, AS AMENDED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON LABOR, PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT.
CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 2 WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATOR SATO.
SO SATO NØ SKINNER, WERE THERE?
NO AMENDMENTS? THEY WERE. YES.
SO MANY AMENDMENTS. OH, I MOTION
IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED, TO THE
COMMITTEE ON LABOR, PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT.
CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 3, WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATOR.
SKINNER. SKINNER. AYE. 43. THANK
YOU, WE'RE GOING ON TO ITEM TEN
AB 2661 MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ENERGY, UTILITIES
AND COMMUNICATION. CURRENT VOTE
IS 5 TO 0 WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. SENATOR SATO. SATO. AYE.
SKINNER SKINNER. AYE. SEVEN
ZERO. CLOSE THE VOTE. ITEM 11 AB
2791. NO, NO, THAT'S. NO. WE GOT
PULLED. OH SORRY. SORRY. ITEM
1212 AB 3259. MOTION IS TO PASS
THE COMMITTEE ON REVENUE AND
TAXATION. CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 1
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATOR SATO. NO. SATO. NO.
SKINNER SKINNER. AYE. 5 TO 2.
THANK YOU. MOVING ON TO ITEM 14
AB 3012. MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HOUSING. CURRENT VOTE IS 5 TO 0
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATOR SATO AYE. SATO AYE.
SKINNER AYE. SKINNER. AYE. SEVEN
ZERO VOTE IS CLOSED. MOVE ON TO
ITEM 15 AB 3068. MOTION IS TO
PASS, AS AMENDED, TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HOUSING. CURRENT
VOTE IS 3 TO 2 WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. SENATOR SATO NØ.
SATO. NÓ. SKINNER. SKINNER AYE.
43 AND LAST WE HAVE ITEM 16 AB
3177. MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HOUSING. CURRENT VOTE IS 42,
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATOR SKINNER. SKINNER AYE.
FIVE. TWO. TWO. THOSE ARE ALL.
AND SHE NEEDS TO BE ADDED ON THE
CONSENT. OKAY. WE'LL GO BACK TO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. VOTES.
MOTION IS ADOPTED. CONSENT
CALENDAR. SENATORS. SKINNER.
SKINNER I'M 7 TO 0. CLOSE THE
VOTES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE. EVERYONE. ALL THE
STAFF FOR THE COMMITTEE DID
EXCEPTIONAL WORK. ALWAYS DO
EXCEPTIONAL WORK. THANK YOU. AND
TO THE STAFF OF ALL THE AUTHORS
OF THE BILLS. THANK YOU EVERYONE
FOR YOUR HARD WORK. WHAT ELSE DO
WE HAVE TO DO? I JUST HAVE TO
SAY THANK YOU. GOODBYE. THANK
YOU TO EVERYONE WHO CAME,
ESPECIALLY IF YOU CAME FROM OUT
OF TOWN. YOU PARTICIPATED IN
PERSON IN THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY.
IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY,
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE.
AND YOUR PARTICIPATION IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO US. THANK YOU FOR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION. WE'VE
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA.